hi this is an ALT shift X live stream
today we're going to talk about A Song
of Ice and Fire The Game of Thrones
books in comparison to Dune there's a
lot of interesting similarities uh this
stream was aziz's idea I've got a
special guest today Aziz from history of
Westeros thanks for coming on Aziz
hey thanks for having me yeah this is
this
that's kind of it's so much fun to talk
about parallels it's one of the things
we do over on my channel and this
usually it's historical parallels to A
Song of Ice and Fire or Parallels Within
A Song of Ice and Fire Within the own
the the history of itself
today we've got more of a fantasy series
Sci-Fi series to another and two big
ones and that's really cool because kind
of discussion is very Niche but really
fun for anyone who likes both series
yeah it's funny because like Dune and
Game of Thrones are both so famous and
popular but I think a lot of people
don't immediately see the similarities
between them because they are different
in a lot of ways like Dune is the
science fiction series and it's got this
sort of dense philosophical tone to it
whereas you know Game of Thrones is the
medieval fantasy and so there are these
superficial differences to it but I
think the more you look you see how both
series play with the same tropes and the
same archetypes and um really
interesting ways so I'm excited to talk
about all these similarities
yeah it's going to be very like
deconstructive and very meta and we're
gonna have to constantly ask ourselves
is this a Trope that they both use is
this a influence that they've both
tapped into or is this genuinely
something that George R Martin
borrowed or was influenced by directly
from Frank Herber and occasionally
that's going to be hard to determine or
it might be a case of both and of course
we have to reckon for whether it's
subconscious or conscious and we will
never be to know that but it'll be fun
regardless Yeah It's tricky to know for
sure but uh fortunately you've done your
research so our first example is one
that we actually do know that George
Martin did deliberately in terms of
similarities between Ned Stark and later
were tradies from Dune
yeah we have a quote here that he did or
that rather that comes from an interview
that he did
and this is actually a translation
because he did this interview I think
was it Russian yeah it was Russian and
they were trying to ask him about of all
things that very related to this they
were asking him about Tolstoy influences
on A Song of Ice and Fire and that's an
important note here given what George
says which is or eddard Stark is a great
example I always understood that he was
not going through the finale of the
first volume here the model for me was
not Tolstoy but rather the science
fiction Frank Herbert and his Dune Frank
knew that the Duke of Summer would die
within the first part after which the
reader's attention shifted to the fate
of his son and daughter it went it seems
to me a little further than Herbert Ned
Stark held out much longer and he is an
important character not a secondary one
so the reader sees the world including
his eyes talking about the famous Martin
POV point of view characters
and the more impact the death has of
course and so that's our first major
comparison as you can see from the
thumbnail perhaps Duke Leto and Ned
Stark and the parallels here are just
all over the place there's a ton of them
and some of them are also related to
plots related to him and not directly
these two characters so this in
particular is a very rich part of our
set of connections for sure
yeah because they're both like held up
as Paragons of honor and morality
um at the same time as being these like
feudal Lords who rule over big chunks of
land and they have this huge power and
they have this huge responsibility and
they're presented as like a model of how
to use power well
um and they are a father figure you know
Ned is a beloved father to to John and
Arya and Sansa and Rob and all the
Starks and lato is a beloved father of
Paul and a and uh and a beloved lover of
their partner lato's lady Jessica and
Ned's lady Catelyn have like a really
wholesome loving relationship so they're
sort of like the idealized father in
both stories I think
yeah that's that's well said and gets to
the point really well the they are that
role within the story as well which is
part of this which is certainly we could
call a Trope the father figure that dies
kind of early-ish or I say ish because
of Ned Stark Casey it's it's ish he's
still fairly early in the in the scheme
of what would be I guess seven or eight
books but it doesn't feel that early
when you're reading it for the first
time it's like oh wow yeah it's
definitely like rather it does feel
stacked it's like a First Act death that
then Spurs on the heroes like like the
death of the father is like the inciting
incident that's that that feeds the
conflict of of like the main story
yeah and I really like what you said too
about how they're both seen as good
examples of power and using power and
how that's a
a model that is hard to repeat and
especially when times become difficult
and people are willing to
really dirty and underhanded and that's
when someone like Ned or Leto is uh a
bit of fish out of water which is part
of both of their stories oh it's almost
literally true for the Duke because
he's comes from a water planet right and
he goes to it
so the Fish Out of Water Works
particularly well for him but then you
know Ned Stark is
he's obviously out of his depth when it
comes to Intrigue that's a plot line
that comes up early and maintains itself
for a long time it's like he's not that
good at this his intentions are very
clearly good you can see that much but
is clearly getting fooled by people he's
not making a lot of progress and then it
just backfires on him he ends up in
prison yeah like it's it's you can see
the the parallels there especially when
the way they are both brought into it I
love this part uh you have
they both knew it was bad they both knew
they were getting into danger like Ned
has the moment where he's trying to
decide whether he should even go at all
and he and maester Lewin and Catelyn are
debating it and you know the show
reverses the way the books do it but
either way it ends up the same decision
of yes I'll go and it's the same with
letter like he then and one of the
reasons the logic is that well we can't
really refuse we have to go or Robert
will trust us or refusing is worse than
going uh so even if going is dangerous
and it's very similar for lead I was
like well we have to we have to accept
this you know even though he's even
though we know it's a trap we have to
walk into the Trap and and you know
survive it and even despite the fact
that we're gonna we're gonna walk into a
trap we're going to be able to hopefully
that'll be enough to survive it and then
we can come out ahead but of course that
doesn't happen
yeah yeah it's it's striking how similar
it is like lato is forced by the emperor
to take control of arrakis and Ned is
forced by the king to take control as
hand of the king like like they both uh
are chosen like that to take power and
they both do it
kind of unwillingly lato is more willing
than than Ned is I would say and yeah as
you say they both know that this
political situation is dangerous but
they both go into it anyway and and they
die for it and they both and they both
are capable politicians but like not not
devious enough they both underestimate
the willingness of their political
enemies to destroy them
um yeah because neither of them are soft
right but they are not cunning like
they're both strong authoritative and
willing to make tough decisions but they
are not hunting they're not and they
don't see cunning as well yeah I yeah I
I would definitely say though that I
think the Dune books show us a more sort
of dark and conniving side to lato that
a lot of the adaptations don't capture
like it we cover this in like the real
Dune video on Old shift X which talks
about how the Atreides really do a lot
of like sneaky nasty immoral stuff in
terms of how they treat civilians and
using propaganda and and their whole
like plan to exploit the framing so like
there is definitely like a a darkness
and a you know conniving nature to the
Atreides but but I think there is also a
bit of a parallel to that with the
stocks in A Song of Ice and Fire as well
because A Song of Ice and Fire like the
Starks are presented as these great
heroic good Lords who everyone respects
and you know the grand or the conspiracy
everyone wants the Starks to come back
but you know there's hints of Darkness
to the stocks like when you read the
world of Ice and Fire world book and
like the History Section with the Starks
is just and then the brutals kings of
winter subjugated the marsh King and
took his daughters and then they
subjugated the barracking and then they
subject like they were brutal Warlords
who took over the north by conquering
and The Killing and and taking the
daughters uh and forcibly marrying and
like doing all these awful things that
is how the Starks took the north
um
so and there's also stories like the
Night's King which is you know this
mythical figure who made a deal with the
white walkers and old Nan hints that the
Night's King might have been a stark and
if we want to get really tinfoil I think
it's a fun theory that the Starks might
literally have the blood of white
walkers in them and that might be this
lovecraftian secret so so I won't go on
too much but I I think that A Song of
Ice and Fire also has a sort of hidden
Darkness to their supposedly Noble
heroic family which I suspect might come
to the fore in later books
I agree I think there's those were
really good examples and there's maybe a
few more like just the fact that Ned
executes a white walker I mean a white
walker that would be amazing no Ned
executes a night's Watchmen in the very
first chapter after the prologue right
that's that wasn't a evil but it was
uh a mistake I suppose at least not to
listen to him you know maybe he had no
choice based on the laws but it was
definitely not a good guy thing an odd
way to present a a heroic figure yeah to
start off uh especially given what we
know about the Night's Watch and the
fact that that guy really did see a
white walker I mean damn like that was
rough so you know you you forgive it
because of the circumstance and the fact
that Ned's ignorant of what that man
really saw and the fact that he's acting
insane and but bran asks the question
like well you know he was afraid and was
he insane and
that obviously sets up a lot of the
things you're talking about then fast
forward to much later in the story when
we learn that the north itself the
practice of worship of the old gods
which has been led by the Starks
included yeah yeah things like human
sacrifice and and
first night and awful other Traditions
that are nowhere near the province of
good guys
yeah yeah yeah I totally agree and also
like there's there's a lot we don't know
about nid personally like like we think
we know a lot of what happened at the
tower of joy and what happened at
Starfall when Ned took the sword Dawn
back to Starfall and then ashara Dane
killed herself like what what really
happened with ashara what really
happened with lyanna and rhaegar in the
tower of Joy like my point is that there
could be bad things that Ned did that we
don't yet know about so there's
definitely more room to sort of
um deepen and darken nid's past and yeah
like as we were talking about like the
the history stuff there's another great
parallel in that the Starks have ruled
the north for supposedly some like 8 000
years or 6 000 years uh and there's a
similar number for how long the tradies
have supposedly ruled calendar like it's
a ridiculously unrealistically long time
that these dsts have survived and I
think the implication in in both is that
the way that you survive as a ruler for
thousands of years is by being
occasionally brutal and your point is
great about you know we are introduced
to Ned Stark chopping off a dude's head
and we see that through Bran's
perspective and bran feels has mixed
feelings about this he's like wow I love
my dad because he's so kind and loving
but also wow my dad is a lord who cuts
off people's heads like and I think that
do you know in A Song of Ice and Fire
are making the same point about power
here in how Power by its nature sort of
sort of corrupts people and forces
people to make these really tough
choices that are sometimes dehumanizing
and sometimes make us compromise our
morals and sometimes Force us to do bad
things so so Dune and A Song of Ice and
Fire are both definitely about power and
how power affects people
yeah no matter what you do you're going
to harm people when you're wielding
power on that scale and that's part of
the lens through which you have to view
these characters
and the ancestry is such a big part of
it you're right that not only are their
father's a big deal but the grandfather
figure is a big deal for yeah
Duke you know the Old Duke they call him
right in Dune that he's such an
important figure the way he's his
bravery and all these these examples he
set and how well he's remembered Rick
aard Stark is a pretty important figure
for how things are set up in A Song of
Ice and Fire you find out and of course
his death the hands of Aries and that's
obviously really important but the
things he was doing before that
the Great Northern or Southern
conspiracy whatever parts of that you
believe some of it were certainly The
Happening uh some degree so
that's pretty familiar as well although
those kind of intrigues are always going
to be part of any sort of political
story high Intrigue uh goes with
royal families and dynasties and
Bloodlines and and that's a feature of
the World building that's really similar
despite the fact that one is taking
place in space and one is taking place
very
stubbornly low aggressively stubbornly
low-tech environment it stayed that way
so long now which interestingly I think
is is something that Dune uses as well
and it's one of my favorite it's a
slight diversion here of things about
Dune and how he wrote it to avoid the
technology problem was to build in the
whole but Larry and Jihad to explain why
certain
Technologies which must have seemed
inevitable in his in his time which are
you know kind of happening in our time
now
are now uh he wrote in why those things
aren't
part of the world and create a
compelling reason for why thinking
machines don't exist and there's similar
not as direct but undertones of
reducing technology or keeping things in
a dark age and or magic having
uh comings and goings on a grand scale
in terms of how you know like the Comet
or uh how certain eras of A Song of Ice
and Fire seem to have magic seems to
work better uh Age of Heroes versus like
now being times where it seems to work
particularly well uh even if we don't
know why so yeah there's a lot of that
and that's I think that's a part of the
World building that like you said it's
hard to notice that because it's
Fantasy Versus sci-fi even though one is
a you know Dune has a lot of fantasy
elements to it I would say which is you
know that's not a pejorative by any
means I I love fantasy so yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah both Westeros and the Dune
Imperium seem to be like technologically
stagnant
um or even going technologically
backwards and they both have in World
law reasons for that like Dune
technology doesn't progress because
they've got this butlerian Jihad Banning
computers and A Song of Ice and Fire
westerosa's Technology doesn't develop
possibly because of the long night
because the white walkers keep turning
up like the Reapers in Mass Effect and
wiping people out like it's not
confirmed but some people speculate that
the White Walker long night might be a
cycle that happens over and over and
well well and and I mean I mean that's
very speculative another simple
explanation is The Irregular Seasons
like when you have a winter that is
sometimes two years and sometimes ten
years and that kills lots of people
that's going to set you back
technologically so like there are
in-universe reasons why westerosa's
technology is kind of stagnant and
likewise with Dune
yeah and what's cool about both of them
and this is something that isn't really
a one borrowing from the other so much
as a a really fun Trope that's used in
both fantasy and sci-fi is the idea of
powerful objects from another time or to
powerful objects that are otherwise in a
lower Tech environment Dune has some
incredibly high-tech things mixed in
with you can't barely use like something
more than a calculator right yeah yeah
and like these incredible personal
energy Shields and other incredible
Technologies like the the still suit
versus Firebase and fire has something
comparisons like that like Valerian
steel or glass candles these are of
course more explained by Magic than
technology but they have the same effect
on the story in terms of what what it
allows to be possible and the way people
seek after these items because of their
value in that setting and
in some cases they're extremely
necessary you must have them or else
yeah and that's yeah uh there's there's
even some some more examples in that I'm
sure I'm missing what do you got well I
think one of the central ones is in Dune
nuclear weapons or atomics are like this
crucially important weapon that there
are all these rules prohibiting the
houses from using them and that is like
one of the key key forms of power in
this world and that's really similar to
the dragons in A Song of Ice and Fire
like George Martin has compared the
dragons to nuclear weapons
um and the dragons are also a power that
is tightly controlled and only the
targaryens want to have power over them
except for certain events in the dance
of the Dragons so um so I think there's
a big similarity there
um is it something else I wanted like
you mentioned before Rickard Stark the
father of Ned Stark being similar to The
Old Duke the father of lato I I think
like both of those characters are a
great parallel in how they die because
the Old Duke father of lato Paul's
grandfather famously died when he was
fighting a bull in the arena as a
matador so The Old Duke put himself in
danger and put himself in the path of
this dangerous monster and died for it
um and that's similar to I guess that's
more similar to Brandon Stark Ned's
brother who went to King's Landing
saying oi rhaegar come out and die and
Brandon went and faced the Mad King
aerys and
um and then what happened like Aries had
well Rickards Rickard accepts the
challenge yeah he goes all because it's
uh he says I'll fight you yeah I can
fight one of the King's Guard right and
then they get burned of course yeah so
so Rickard like like The Old Duke went
and faced the Monstrous Aries and it was
a fight that he thought he could win but
but he died as a result of his you know
confidence and his attempt to win so um
so and I guess that sort of frames like
the political conflict of The Next
Generation like like the grandfather of
the hero boldly fought and died and so
like the lesson to the to the grandson
to the hero is well maybe I need to be
smarter about this Paul and and the
Stark kids they both sort of know that
you know
overconfidence and directness got there
got their fathers and grandfathers
killed so like you've got to be smarter
and more political to survive
yeah and then this brings up who the
Rivals are that are their main danger to
survival in the first place which yeah
parallels between Lannister and harkinen
are pretty rich including their vast
wealth
see what I did there and they're
absurdly wealthy both of them and for
the same time scale as applied to the
other houses in both settings so
Arkansas have been Rich for a crazy long
time and uh
the Harkins as well yeah you know both
of them yeah I I like the idea though
that like while the stocks and the
Atreides are both these very very
ancient houses of this special ancient
bloodline the Lannisters and the
hakunans are more new money they are
more recent Powers because the
Lannisters like they constantly rock is
not their ancestral seat the Lannisters
stole casterly Rock from the casterlies
land the clever right and and then they
started exploiting the gold mines so
their new money who used economic
activity and trade to get rich the
hearkenings are the same because the
Hawkings were like cast down and exiled
in the Battle of Corin but then they
recently regained power through I think
the quote is adroit manipulation of the
whale fur Market or whatever
of course that's the thing that you get
rich from because I of course we all
knew that whales had fur oh I'm wearing
my whale for a cloak right now
um so so I think it's really interesting
that like there's sort of this taint of
there being something kind of immoral
about getting rich from trade as opposed
to just being an honor like an ancient
family like the Starks and the Atreides
um the Lannisters and Hawkins both made
money recently they are new money they
are the upstarts who are the rivals to
the rightful old dynastic family
um which yeah I think is really cool
and you know we'll have to come back to
one of these partial comparisons because
of course these aren't all one-to-one
comparisons but I think the the in terms
of actual character is the best
one-to-one comparison we have for a
hearkening is coming later so teaser for
later in the episode here yeah that's a
huge one especially because another
thing I like about that is just how
way it's set up uh in terms of what
they're up against you're up against in
terms of when you're reading Game of
Thrones and not necessarily later when
the story expands and you've got a lot
more characters and a lot more houses
but when you're focused on Stark and
Lannister you've got this exact same
thing you're walking into there
a character who's walking into their
territory what they think is their
territory meaning the red keep or Iraqis
something that they've had that they're
maybe losing their grip on and want to
get back and
one of the things we
about being the hand is that for a lot
of people it's an opportunity to wield
power and we'll unscrupulously you can
make a lot of money at it and that's
kind of a similar thing here it's not as
direct as it is in Dune where the spice
is this just
obscenely valuable do everything
substance that obviously control over
that is going to mean a lot whereas even
but even for someone like Leto who's not
going to exploit that as much as someone
like Harkins would to just an
extraordinary degree the same thing is
going to be true for Ned Stark where the
main thing he's given is political power
and legal power executive power and he
uses that to almost pick a fight with
the Lannisters anyway because of the the
small scale
capture of Tyrion and and
um false blame placed on
him for the murder of
Bran or the attempted murder of bran so
that part is where things are a little
different because the the dune
uh well maybe you could say that similar
in Dune in a way is there is the because
because didn't the
uh Iraq are the hearkenin
uh a trades Feud start with some sort of
military campaign snafu from long ago
that was kind of mine yeah but resulted
in yeah or something like that the
battle
hawkinen was exiled for cowardice after
allegations by an Israelis and that's
kind of all we know in the okay so hmm
that might be sort of similar how a
small relatively small scale thing turns
into a feud between two great houses
which by the way something else I forgot
to mention George has lamented not using
the title Duke in A Song of Ice and Fire
because Lord and high Lord are just too
similar and he wants a way to
distinguish between the you know the the
great houses
and just calling them Duke would have
been what a simple way to do that so
that would have been a really obvious
parallel too if he had done that I think
Tywin Lannister would have made a great
Baron
yeah
throw a few hundred pounds on him
um and yeah as as I think you noted
um the Hawkings and the Lannisters are
well the enemies of the hero uh are
similar in that princess Ireland Carino
the the daughter of the villainous
Emperor has blonde hair and green eyes
like how the Lannisters Jamie and Cersei
have blonde hair and green eyes so so I
don't know I I think that one you know
the commonality here is that the bad
guys are rich and the bad guys are
beautiful whereas the good guys are
these sort of noble upright uh ancient
families who are not as wealthy as well
the books both make a point that the
Atreides are not one of the super rich
houses and the Starks are one of the
less Rich great houses so yeah strong
parallels though
they have the similar this connects to
your the anecdote that I wasn't sure
about that you clarified regarding the
the origin of their Feud which is that
the Starks are very well regarded as a
military
uh force or their soldiers are highly
regarded Etc and that was true for the
Duke uh to portraitis as well just the
atrates family in general and that's
something that the
Emperor I suppose and maybe the Harkins
as well are jealous of is his reputation
because uh you know they they're Petty
like that and I think that was some
extent that's going to be true
or some of the relationships Within
long advice and fire maybe some of them
Stark and Lannister they're not as
direct I suppose but they become that
way as the few develops early on it's
been doing I suppose that Feud has
existed already for a long time yeah and
there's definitely that idea in both
stories that you know that the honorable
later and The Honorable Ned destroyed
early on by the conniving enemies but
the legacy of the heroic honorable later
and Ned lives on so like in Dune there's
the there's the skull Shrine of lato
that becomes this importance lasting
symbol of a trait of the Atreides and
you know Ned Stark's bones like later
skull Ned's bones become this plot point
in the books where where the bones are
returning to Winterfell and and that's
important and and the bones represent
the legacy of these characters they may
have been defeated but their ideals live
on and continue to inspire people and
you know that the whole Grand Northern
Conspiracy plot line shows how the
people of the north still want the
Starks in Winterfell
um similar to how you know later Legacy
in the Atreides Legacy is part of what
Paul evokes
um so that so they both they both lost
and certainly like the protagonists
compare themselves to their fathers and
there's always this question of like can
I live up to my father's ideals while
also not being defeated as my father was
so yeah that's great yeah there's a lot
of that in the song of ice and fire but
sticking just to this family it's pretty
big because we're seeing and obviously
it's not played out fully even though
he's been dead for a while the legacy of
Tywin Lannister is pretty bad right
there's just all these things are going
wrong because of he made so many enemies
he he was so ruthless and mistreated so
many people including his own family
that you're not living by his values
they're not living by the value people
aren't still remembering him the way
they do Ned Stark or like oh now there's
an opening he that he's now that he's
dead you know it's a different sort of
uh it's opportunistic now the taiwan's
gone we have the ministers are weak
rather than oh Ned is gone Let's help
save his daughter right that's a very
big difference yeah yeah uh
although
sorry go on
quick one that I forgot to mention
earlier that's a really neat quote is
faint within a faint within a faint is a
line from Dune and wheels within Wheels
within Wheels comes up a couple times in
Ned's Arc so yeah I love that it's just
that's a pretty clear one I don't think
that one's intentional but because it's
so subtle but maybe it is because it's
so similar but uh yeah I guess we'll
probably never know yeah yeah both
stories are very sort of like
self-consciously about intricate
political plots and yeah using that same
little pattern is a fun way to highlight
that
uh thanks for the super chats by the way
gonna uh in a Super Chat points out that
uh just as the stocks moved from a cold
climate into a warmer climate uh the
Atreides moved from a cooler climate on
uh Caledon to the hot climate on arrakis
which is cool and uh thanks also yeah
Maura who says show of support thanks
for all the great content and uh thanks
Super Rad who says Paul the trades is
Azora High we'll get to that
so we are maybe a good Segway Point here
is one the way that their ending happens
for both of them uh which is
when Ned Stark is
basically has no choice left he's in
prison he's dying and he is effectively
willing to throw his life away until his
daughter is threatened
virus comes to him and gives him a
chance to
do that help his family make his death
count for something and
Paris that's also is advancing his goals
it's something that will that Ned will
want to do and on the other side in Dune
we have Dr Huey who also is not
necessarily isn't a loyal person like uh
or is a loyal person not unlike varus
but was nevertheless trusted with some
important things and is you always
forced into what he's doing because of a
threat to his own family but
nevertheless he's doing a similar thing
here where he's
helping someone else get revenge uh as
as part of their death right helping
which is kind of part of that Legacy
thing we were talking about in a as like
a striking beyond the group from Beyond
the Grave kind of thing that they both
have in common
as they fade stage exit stage left
yeah yeah so like Varys convinces Ned to
falsely confess to treason in order to
protect his kids protect Sansa and yui
convinces leito to use the poison tooth
to try and kill Vladimir so yeah in
their Darkest Hour they both to protect
his wife too yeah yeah yeah right
yeah so they so they both sort of die in
a way that sort of besmirches their own
honor
um and they both are visited by a schema
who sort of gives them a chance to make
their death mean something so yeah huge
parallel
oh
so how about we move on to um some of
like the political background is really
similar in both stories
um because both worlds have this
foundational political balance where
there's the Supreme King on the Iron
Throne or there's in Dune there's the
emperor on the lion Throne the throne is
called the lion throne in tune I am
thrown fire don't tell me that's a
coincidence
and and one of the sort of fundamental
plot points is that in Dune Empress Adam
doesn't trust and is jealous of uh
later's power which is similar to how
King aerys Targaryen in in the backstory
of Game of Thrones was mistrustful and
jealous of everybody his son Prince
rhaegar and his hand Tywin and
um and that's part of what sparked the
conflict of Robert's Rebellion
yeah and in Dune we have Lance Rod which
is basically an alliance of the great
houses which
they're a check against the power of the
emperor if the emperor gets out of line
they'll all hang up and together they're
stronger than he is and it's a way to
prevent tyranny it's a way to it's
imbalance and that's sort of what was
lacking in Westeros the targaryens
didn't have that check
for a long time but fast forward to the
time of Aries and they lost that check
because they don't have dragons anymore
and but it had been some time since they
had lost dragons but no one had really
challenged them except for
challenges within their own family if we
count things like the blackfyers but
that's again a Cadet branch of their own
so outside threats didn't really happen
until something that was very recent
within the time frame of The Song of Ice
and Fire
Robert's Rebellion is mentioned
constantly early on in the Game of
Thrones it's a huge part of the framing
for the story in the setting sorry one
second technology
yeah sorry
can you all hear me are we back let me
know in the live chat if we're all okay
I think we're back as these sorry
can you hear me Aziz
all right right back I suppose he'll
I'll just keep filling in here while uh
all right we're all good is this sorry
about that so yeah the lion the lens rat
is basically the great houses and what
we see at the beginning of Robert's
Rebellion is Aries pushing too hard
against the
implied feudal vassal relationship which
is that hey I'm your king but if
something goes wrong and there's an
outside threat I'll organize everything
and get everyone together and command
and stop that threat and in the meantime
you pay me taxes and bend the knee and
all that but if you just murder me out
of hand without any Fair Justice behind
that well that's not okay and in Dune
there is a system against that they've
been around long enough to have fixed
that sort of thing that system doesn't
exist in A Song of Ice and Fire but it
was what people like Rickard and
uh Hoster Tully were trying to create
they were trying to create more of a
check on the Royal house that's the
basic idea of the South run conspiracy
which is
a series of marriages and alliances that
would keep Aries from doing anything to
doing too much
for the Royal House going you know
Thinking Beyond Aries once he's
eventually gone and rhaegar was
basically behind that and of course
that's kind of what's too bad about the
fact that it came to war and Robert
kildregar because rhaegar would have
probably been a reasonable one to work
with but as it turned out Aries ignited
all that and the story went the way it
did and that's very similar to what
happens in Dune
except that it had happened it's it's
happening in the during the story
instead of maybe 15 years prior so
obviously there's going to be some
differences here and there between uh
these parallels and how they're used
within the story but that's pretty cool
to see these parallels
yeah yeah what's that line where another
one we have here is
both of them are corrupt ancient
dynasties
that have held supreme power for a long
time and that is obviously uh something
that's
they're losing for various reasons uh in
this case the most direct parallel would
be just being a bad paranoid leader that
can't handle oneself in his
unable to maintain the sort of composure
and lack of ego
that goes into wielding this kind of
supreme power
technical difficulties we'll be back in
one second
foreign
but he is nevertheless
a bit soft at least on someone sitting
in such a important position can you
hear me as Ace
I sure can all right we're good we're
back sorry about that
no prob I filled in a little of that
while you were gone yeah yeah we're all
good
um yeah I wanted to add uh with that
idea of like the the southern Ambitions
great houses and rhaegar all plotting to
get together and to uh put checks to
reduce ares's power like that line that
rhaegar has before he goes into battle
that Jaime remembers where it's like a
council will be called changes will be
made that was yeah that was rhaegar's
attempt to try and uh change things and
um I think it's really similar to how
Paul I think it's Paul talks about the
lands red you know we need I could bring
evidence to the lands rat that Emperor
shadam tried to destroy uh the Atreides
with sadaka and when we sort of present
that to the Lancer at Council then we'll
be able to reduce shaddam's power like
that's a very very similar
um idea that and in both cases it
doesn't work it doesn't happen that the
houses don't uh get together to stop
shadam it's it's Paul's doing and the
fremin's doing and rhaegar and the
southern Ambitions Alliance fails to put
checks on Aries so so there's a there's
a failure of like sort of political due
process that causes the heroes to have
to go and solve the problems instead
yeah and almost a similar thing happens
with Ned's Arc as well where he's trying
to
create or gather enough evidence to
present to Robert but it all becomes
irrelevant because Robert just dies and
it's sketchy whether Robert would have
or Robert would have done about it as
well so yeah it's neat how this is a
diver almost a diversionary tactic than
these uh story lines that both authors
like to use rather than just engaging in
more straightforward tropes they sort of
set it up one way and then kind of take
a right turn maybe maybe a second right
turn after that yeah forks I I think
there's a sense in both stories that
like you know they both are these
medieval-ish feudal-ish political
systems and they both fail to uh stop
their tyrannical leaders King Aries
Empress Adam both feudal systems are
failing and so like there's there's a
sense in both stories that we need to
change this system like we need to
dramatically change this monarchical
feudal system because it's it's creating
Injustice and it's creating Horrors and
so a big part of what the June series is
about is is exploring different
political systems and and changing
things to make a better universe and I'm
really curious about what A Song of Ice
and Fire will do like it's interesting
that at the end of The Game of Thrones
TV show we have King bran in charge of
Westeros and the show never really
explores what that means or like why why
is it a good thing for King bran to be
in charge but I think that you know we
anticipate that if it is that bran
becomes king in the yet to be published
Game of Thrones books uh I think it'll
explore like you know how King bran will
be a different political system and how
it will be better to avoid the horrors
of the past but I we can talk more about
King bran and dune a bit later on at the
moment we're doing like no spoilers or
light spoilers for dune in this live
stream but later on in the live stream
we will talk more about spoilers and
we'll warn you when we do talk about any
big spoilers for June yes the god
emperor of Westeros is coming later
that's right
shall we talk about Jessica and Catlin
he should we should indeed because they
are another good set of related
parallels starting with just kind of
some obvious physical features like
they're both redheads and they're the
wife
or concubine in Jessica's case but it's
very functionally very similar of this
doomed Father Figure type and
is a doomed mother figure Jessica not so
much it's not not really the same in
that sense so that's a that's a
Divergence which is uh nice to see as
well and they're both
someone that had to really adjust to a
new living situation right they are not
from
the place that they have to settle and
have children catelyn's not from the
north Jessica's not from Caledon and
that parallels within each other the
stories that we just set up for whereas
Ned goes into a very unfamiliar
situation to be hand to the king and
Duke Leto goes into a very similar
situation going from Caledon to Iraqis
which is very unfamiliar both in terms
of well in terms of everything it's just
really unfamiliar geographically
politically and and you know all that
yeah I think it's interesting that you
know while Ned Stark and later trades
are sort of the idealized father where
like the children have nothing but love
and respect for their father in both
June and A Song of Ice and Fire the the
mother
you know Catelyn and Jessica are not as
idealized and I think they have more
complicated relationships with some of
their children I mean John especially
obviously has a really complicated
relationship with Catelyn who is not his
mother and who rejects him even like
Arya I think has you know a somewhat
more difficult relationship with with
Catelyn
um I mean there are certain Revelations
about Jessica and dune that complicate
her relationship with Paul as well
um yeah yeah but but I think it's
interesting that like it it's definitely
um I think it's a more complicated and a
more layered
relationship with the mother as opposed
to the father Ned and later who are who
are idolized by their children
yeah and that's true there's it is more
complicated and I think the fact that
there's also more children in The Song
of Ice and Fire setting complicates it
as well because they do have varying
relationships I mean just checking
uh that come you used on as an example
that's obviously a stark example because
the relationship with Catelyn but then
there's is more straightforward examples
like Rob and then there's Arya who
arguably has a better relationship with
Ned than with Catelyn and Sansa who is
probably the reverse of that whereas
all is
that's obviously not the only child but
kind of effectively the only child in
the first book and
a big deal and it changes especially in
a
power Dynamic like they have with with
errors and and Bloodlines and all that
so something
um
a similarity is that both Jessica and
Catelyn are very much motivated by
wanting to protect their children but at
the same time wanting to advance their
children politically uh Jessica you know
more so than in the movies Jessica in
the books very much wants Paul to be
restored to the leadership of House of
Trades and to be politically powerful
and and Catelyn Catelyn in the books
more than in the TV show wants her
children wants Rob to be the Lord to be
restored to uh ruling their Homeland
um they're both politically ambitious
and like it very much explores how
there's a tension between wanting to
love and protect your children but also
wanting them to have political power
because of course having political power
is dangerous so you know if you if you
love your children should you want them
to be Lords and Kings because that's
dangerous and that's attention that I
think both of these stories explore
yeah and that is the heart of one of the
most direct detailed parallels I think
we might have between these two
characters which is the
core plot for both of them very early on
is Catelyn trying to figure out who
killed bran and Jessica trying to figure
out who killed Paul or how
I was almost killed yeah it's a Chris
knife and a dagger with a dragon bone
Hilt which of lyrion Steel and these are
both key parts of that and you have a
secret message from Margot fenring at
least in the book version with a secret
code written that only in a way that
only Jessica can understand because
she's been a Jester it and there's a
warning about the harkenings meanwhile
Lysa in a language that only Catelyn can
understand
warns her about the Lannisters now this
is a false warning but still it's the
same kind of thing where it's an early
plot point where they get this message
that steers their actions in a very
direct and important way and it's
related to
threats on not just them but their
children specifically
and said advancement or lack thereof
that you mentioned so that yeah it's
really really huge similarity there even
though those plots have huge differences
as well these similarities are like oh
yeah that's yeah I see that once you see
them anyway yeah yeah they both
investigate the attempted murder murder
of their son they both have a special
knife as a key piece of evidence they
both get a warning from a woman in a
coded message I I mean surely George had
dude in mind when he wrote this and and
you know you note that lice's warning to
Catelyn is a
political Ploy from Littlefinger trying
to manipulate Catelyn because
um because littlefinger's trying to turn
the Starks in the Lannisters against
each other but but I think in a similar
way we can question Margot fan Rings uh
motivations when she sends that coded
message to Jessica in the June book
because you know we know that the
fenrings are connected to the empress
Adam and we know that the fenrings uh
are working with the Benny Jesuit and
and Jessica's goals are not entirely
aligned with the Bena Jesuit so I think
that the complicated relationship
between Catelyn and Lisa is similar to
the complicated relationship between
Jessica and the Benny Jesuit and Margot
for sure
okay right on yeah I guess I didn't
catch that part but now that you lay it
out I'm like oh yeah okay
yeah right on there's definitely like
like deeper more complicated
um politics and like factional issues
with Jessica than with Catelyn but we've
always got to remember that you know
Catelyn is not not born as stuck Catelyn
is a Tully and and Catelyn is connected
to the Aarons through her through her
sister and so you know Catelyn has these
political and cultural and religious
differences from NED and the Starks
which which complicate her relationship
with her partner
yeah and they were both of their
marriages were very directly related
to the plotting uh yeah prior
Generations catelyn's marriage to
not just Ned but it was originally going
to be brand and star because that
marriage was so important that they
passed it down to the next Sun
and similarly Jessica's marriage to
gleno was
a lot of people had an interest in that
but particularly I guess they've been a
Jester at most of all right would that
be accurate to say
yeah yeah I mean the yeah that that
marriage of well not marriage but that
Partnership of Jessica and lato is part
of the benedra breeding program to try
and create the quiz at satirak so it's
really cool that that both Jessica and
lato's relationship and Catelyn and
Ned's relationship they are both
relationships that started for political
reasons but they both blossomed into
true love which is really lovely
like that yeah it really is that's quite
a cool it's a and people say that these
stories were Grim dark you know but and
I guess they these these characters did
have Bad Endings but they got to have
nice long lives of at least partially
they got to have some time in the Sun
Yeah well yeah sort of
yeah well yeah it's important that like
the the hero protagonist characters get
to see this model of like idealized true
love in their parents before it is lost
so in the same way that the heroes like
Paul and Jon Snow that they ask
themselves you know can I be as
honorable as my father they also ask
themselves can I have a true love like
my like you know Ned had with Catelyn
and like Jessica had with later like it
it establishes those ideals of love and
heroism for the protagonist to strive
for and struggle for as The Story Goes
On yeah something to keep continuously
remember and and George likes to invert
that where we also have a character
Tyrion and then Jamie Ann Cersei as well
who are showing us the opposite showing
this yeah
that by their leg they're constantly
thinking about their father and it's not
a good thing it's usually it's like oh
it makes me feel bad you know or it's
well my father would have done this and
it's something awful you know yeah yeah
that's right just as Jamie says he and
Terry and grapple with their shitty
father tywin's Legacy we see how erilan
has to Grapple with her monstrous father
shaddam's Legacy and you know Fate has
to deal with the baron Vladimir's Legacy
and it's there's sort of a tragedy that
these people who were born into these
who are the children of villainous
fathers like they don't necessarily want
to follow in their villainous Father's
Footsteps Tyrion doesn't necessarily
want to be like Tywin
um Ireland doesn't necessarily want to
be like shaddam but there is like this
sense of inevitability about following
in your parents footsteps and just the
political realities you know so there's
that there's there's much about like
Legacy and family and bloodline and
power that that both of these stories
explore
and that's what kind of way I brought up
Tyrion because he's specifically the one
that points out that we are the
puppets that dance on the strings of
those that came before us because that's
that's yeah a nice succinct George way
to say that and maybe maybe George got
that line from Shakespeare or something
because that's another major influence
of his along with along with Dune yeah
yeah
Joe chess some great line about how his
chief influences uh William Shakespeare
and Stanley Marvel Comics which is
wonderful
but then in between there yeah I love it
so our next parallel is uh the scheming
and devious Pita DeVries uh the mentat
assassin who serves the harkenans is
very similar to Littlefinger Peter
Baelish the political schemer in the
small Council
yes indeed we have first of all a Fun
World building aspect of Dune that is
mentat and there is not a direct
equivalent really in A Song of Ice and
Fire I suppose
but there is the
uh example of someone who's just really
good at math and that alone puts them
above everyone else which is a similar
role within the story especially because
these are very unscrupulous people
they're not fully in charge of
their own destiny they have to work for
someone else they're both small
obviously the name is similar yeah I'm
sure you noticed that one already
they one of them has the pointed chin
the other has a chin beard and they're
everybody knows they're not trustworthy
but they're so useful that they
are allowed to stick around
go ahead yeah well there's something I
find like something that recurs again
like we talked about how the hakunans
and the Lannisters are both villainous
and they're both associated with money
and wealth and in a similar way like
like Pi did averies and and Peter like
Littlefinger has this financial Acumen I
mean I guess pi to DeVries is not
associated with money per se but he's
he's like a devious smart mathematically
inclined person and there's there's sort
of the villainy of being a manipulative
nerd which um which is is huge with both
these characters
and we have what their Ambitions are
yeah which is busting after these two
characters we just compared Catelyn and
Jessica the redheads that had all these
other things in common with each other
so that just by extension creates a lot
more parallels
they receive
that they offer
the offer of the cursed Thief that
requires enormous upkeep you know and
player is offered by the baron you can
have Dune or you can have Jessica
and he puts him in that position and he
you know he then Peter actually claims
harrenhal to be worthy of Sansa so it's
a similar kind of need one to have the
other or you can have one or the other
and uh I thought that was cool yeah yeah
but they both like Peter and
Littlefinger are both the like uh nerdy
angry bitter spurned Underdog who wants
power and wants the hot redhead and they
both get tantalizingly close to having
to having it but they don't quite get
there
um which is really cool
a lot
and both of them I think are parallels
uh and contrasts to a more heroic Mentor
so maester Lewin is the wise teacher of
the Stark kids and and he's you know
this really nice well-intentioned guy
even if he's completely wrong about
magic uh and similarly thufia hawat the
mentat is like the good guy version I
mean he's not really a good guy but he's
like the the more heroic version of
Peter DeVries
um who is the Beloved mentor of Paul so
we we get like a a good wise man figure
in Lewin and through fear and we get an
evil conniving smart man in pyter and
Peter
that's pretty cool and we even have a
little bit of
I'm working for The Other Side by force
Lewin had to work for Eon when when they
were yeah taken over by the ironborn uh
that's a pretty small part of his Arc
but it is you know that's how he goes
out
yeah that's a great point the the why
the heroic wise man that they both get
captured by the bad guys and and they
both advise the bad guys Lewin advises
Theon honestly and wisely enthusias
advises larkinens in a slightly more
complicated what he does yeah
and and of course you know
um we we can note that Sofia is a much
more nasty evil dude than the blue one
is because oh yeah is after all a mentat
assassin and his job is murdering people
and you know yeah there's some fun lines
in the books about how the hearkenans
fear through fear or what because he's
just this implacable enemy who just
absolutely will gut the hearkenings at
every opportunity so uh there's
Dean Dune is uh it does lean harder into
um the villainy of even the heroes
because of course June is about
uh deconstructing the idea of heroism
and questioning the idea of heroism but
um I'm sure we'll discuss that more
later
yeah the better comparison for a lot of
what do fear can do is like bloodraven
you know
the highly feared
questionable methods like powers that
maybe he shouldn't have you know kind of
thing yeah true yeah I mean I I think
that's like the fun thing is that like
you know Littlefinger thinks that he's
the master manipulator but then like a
level above him it's more like oh no
illyrio is the master manipulator and
then you're like oh no wait blood Raven
is the master manipulator who's above
them and then you know he'll maybe
quaint is up there as well so um yeah
there's levels to it in a way that I
don't think Dune quite oh well no I mean
Dune does have sort of levels as as the
series goes on
um I won't spoil it but you know after
Paul there are there are other Giga
brain Mega people who are you know it's
sort of there's this power creep in Dune
where there's like a new super powerful
person uh in each book practically so
you know there's
the scale expands in both stories I
suppose there's more Powers behind the
powers just like there is in on a
version fire it is less historical with
the song as in a song which fire a lot
of it is just stuff that's revealed from
long ago
whereas the good stuff yeah just like
there's more players involved as the
situation shifts Etc
and there is a sense in a sunglass and
fire that like the tide of magic is
rising you know dragons are reborn White
Walkers are returning this is an age for
gods and heroes I like the idea that
euron Greyjoy is emerging as like a new
Next Level Supernatural threat so I
guess both stories have this sort of
um Power creep this this increase in
stakes and scale that increases as The
Story Goes On
yeah that's that's a good way to put it
it starts off as a
squabble
in two houses and the Royal House yeah
overshadowing it all and then expands to
include a lot more houses and interests
and
Supernatural slash high tech
uh aspects and goes from there yeah
so much yeah and I think that the scale
and complexity increases so much that
the respective authors lose control of
their stories because you know I I won't
spoil it but you know Dune the ending of
Dune is almost explicitly a moment where
the author kind of explicitly says
oops uh my story I've gotten out of my
control I've gone too far there's all
these crazy characters doing wacky
things and I'm not really sure what's
going on to be entirely honest and uh
like that that is the end of chapter
house and whereas uh A Song of Ice and
Fire uh George I don't think has quite
admitted it to himself yet but I think
the reason why the the song of us and
Fire series is unfinished is largely
because George has introduced too many
characters and plot lines and the scale
has increased and the complexity has
increased and is no longer quite in
control of his own story so I think that
there's a very strong like meta
similarity in how Frank and George both
sort of lost control of their rapidly
expanding universes
I agree that and especially
maybe 20 30 years from now some of these
parallels will seem even or Stark or
more direct or maybe not because maybe
some of them will look less so depending
on how
next 10 15 years actually go but yeah
it's so true especially as well the Arc
of
getting things made into TV shows and
our own personal influences I know we we
had a few notes on that uh in terms of
just like things that they've done where
Dune has a lot of
parallels to the wars in the Middle East
over oil or the drug wars whereas The
Song of Ice and Fire has allegories to
climate change and these aren't
necessarily oh yeah I definitely did
this George isn't George has said that
he didn't do that on purpose you can
he's he's also said you it absolutely
works for that
but it doesn't really even matter in
terms of authorial intent if we're just
talking about what's there and what
isn't and so they both have you can see
the products of from their own time and
things that were important during their
their era uh when they were writers and
all that which I think is always a fun
thing to deconstruct and look at
yeah yeah I mean it's fascinating that
they both are of their time and yet the
stories are so similar despite coming
from such different times I mean the
Dune books were published first in the
60s and Song of Ice and Fire was you
know some 30 years later in the 90s
um and yet they are so similar and I
think that's because like I think that
both Junior and A Song of Ice and Fire
that they are responding
more to Fantasy uh literature and like
tropes more so than they are responding
to like current events
um like June June is very much about
I I mean they both draw from history as
well you know Frank Herbert enormously
was influenced by you know Sabers of
paradise and
um
and uh what's his bloody name the um
the story of the European guy who goes
into the Middle East and takes control
and uh leads the local people and you
know in the same way song of I said
Lawrence of Arabia sorry yeah and you
know song about some fire is very much
about was was of the roses and stuff so
like I think they they both draw more
from history and from literature and
from you know tropes and common stories
than they do from their current time
necessarily I mean I mean Georgia Martin
is riding the Winds of Winter in the
year 2023 but he but the Winds of Winter
is not about the year 2023. The Winds of
Winter is more about the you know 80s
when when George Martin was coming up
you know
um
and George has said as much in
interviews that he he's George is not
writing about 2023 politics in a song of
Ass and Fire he's more responding to
history and more Universal uh cultural
ideas
yeah and that's something that interests
him more in in general the things that
he reads about like he grew up reading
history and
you know he has painted figurines of
knights and he has and he loves you know
Lord of the Rings is a one of his
biggest influences
and yeah so that that sort of thing
history repeating itself the cycles of
history and ancient world or the
medieval world that is more his Jam Even
though he's
unlike a lot of authors he has written
substantial amounts of both he has a big
wide catalog he's written a lot of
sci-fi and he did that before he wrote
Song of Ice and Fire which is probably
where he gets some of that
ability to
use different notes within a familiar
story which helps
be more unique
I think that adds to it overall I'd say
yeah I I think both George and Frank are
writing as much in response to Beowulf
and The Iliad as they are to the
politics of their contemporary time that
they're really reaching for something
more Universal and and I think that's
part of why these series have so much
longevity like Dune is a book that is
being read and enjoyed some 60 years
after its publication and and A Song of
Ice and Fire I suspect will be read for
a long time as well because yeah they're
both reaching for something Universal
rather than chasing any kind of like
current
current Trend or whatever
I wonder how much uh they have in common
regarding doing psychedelic drugs
you must be asked
yeah drugs are definitely a theme in
both stories and in both authors lives
yeah right like I know Herbert
experimented with psychedelic maybe more
than experimented with I'm not quite as
clear on George but he's a huge fan of
the Grateful Dead you know deadhead and
that subculture and
yeah I mean he doesn't have children so
there's nothing really stopping him you
know so yeah and with the the werewood
visions and the way he writes things
like that yeah it might they often have
some experience if you're going to write
prophecies and Visions to maybe had a
few of your own yeah yeah because
obviously spice is the powerful drug
that's at the heart of Dune and there's
also other drugs like sappho and some
Yuta in Dune A Song of Ice and Fire the
drugs aren't as obvious but you have
drugs like the shade of the evening
which Daenerys takes before her visions
and euron also drinks shade of the
evening and interestingly shade of the
evening stains your lips a dark blue
dark purple dark Indigo which is similar
to how the mentats have their lips
stained uh read by the drugs that they
take and the Indigo of shade of the
evening might be a bit like the blue of
the spice in Dune
like that one yeah and the whatever
brand drinks that thing that is
debatedly jojin paste or not seems to
trigger a bunch of Visions as well
so there's that as well as
actors like dreamwine apparently can
maybe cause some Visions I know there's
that famous scene where Jamie has his
vision his dream with Brienne underneath
casually Rock and King's Garden and all
that the ghosts in blue and white
he's under the influence of
game wine and fever and he's got his
head resting on a werewood stump so you
know you've got multiple factors there
too
yeah
shall we talk about the baron the and
illyrio mapatis the conniving fat man at
the uh at the heart of the story pulling
strings
oh let's do it this was the the
character I mentioned that has uh isn't
a Lannister you know isn't a Lannister
within the story in terms of illyrio has
the characteristics of a harkenin which
in early we made the Harkin and
Lannister parallels
both of these large men have rings on
every finger
and as I
my favorite parallel here in terms of
their way they move is that
ethereal is unusually light on his feet
and this the in-world description for
that or reason for that is that he's a
former water dancer
whereas the baron is also unusually
light on his feet and that's because of
the suspensers That's Not Unusual I
guess it just would look unusual when
you're seeing it for the first time now
if you if you watched all the
the various TV shows and movies usually
have him floating but I think in the
book it's more of a just a large a lot
of help but maybe I'm wrong about that I
don't recall exactly either way it's
very similar uh in that sense
yeah yeah I I think that as you say yeah
I think in the Dune book The Baron
doesn't so much levitate and fly he more
is just held up partly by the suspensers
to make him lighter so he's it's almost
like comical the way he's described as
like this big fat baby who sort of
drifts and hops across the ground
lightly as though he's walking on the
moon or something and it's like the the
villain the villanuev Dune movies make
the baron a lot more sort of serious and
dark and a lot more dignified whereas in
the book The Baron is this more
ridiculous comical
over-the-top talkative
um also like uh sort of like negative uh
gay sex criminal stereotype thing this
sort of this homophobic element in Dune
in parts of it but um yeah but yeah the
the baron is is more sort of ridiculous
than over the the top in the books and
yeah definitely similar to Illyria
because illyrio like similar to Vladimir
in the books the baron in the books they
both love the sound of their own voice
and they both talk talk talk talk and
they both have these secrets that they
blab about a little bit too much the
baron there's a couple of moments in the
books where the baron says something and
gives away something and then he's like
oh why did I say that I shouldn't have
given that away
um and in I think the same way like in
illyrio's conversations with Tyrion uh
illyrio says things about oh you know I
have debts of affection to repay and you
know a dragon is still a dragon and he
has all these little lines where he's
sort of he he can't help himself but
sort of hint at his grand scheme which I
think is part of what what leads or will
lead to their undoing so yeah the the
possible connection parallel a lot of
that is
Arya overhearing Varys and illyrio
plotting under the red keep and you know
that's not them blabbing because they
have a very reasonable expectation that
no one's listening but it you know
creates a similar thing where something
gets leaked the way that the audience
can see kind of straightforwardly
yeah
I I think it's you also have this go
ahead
I think it's interesting how both
characters use words like the baron
Vladimir explicitly like Frank was
obsessed with language and and how
language can be used and misused and so
there's times like you know the baron
says oh I promised that I won't kill
Jessica and Paul so therefore I won't
kill Jessica and Paul I will just leave
them in the desert and the desert will
kill Jessica and Paul so it's a sort of
like ridiculous like semi-truth
um and I feel like illyrio plays with
language in similar ways I can't think
of a direct example but illyrio's
illyrio and Varys definitely like play
with like language and appearances Varys
is of course a mama you know he he's a
playwright he takes on disguises and he
and he uses things that are technically
true but not quite so I think there's
similarities there as well
yeah I agree there's a what one example
or two examples that come to mind from
illyrio is is one where he
uh twists Tyrion around regarding the
poisonous mushrooms
and it kind of manipulates him that way
and trying to tricks him into showing
him and you do want to live see I proved
it to you by presenting you with the
choice
and uh another one maybe is
the way he
quitos is way past viserys's temper
tantrums like when he's
take me for a fool he's like oh I take
you for a king because Kings lack the
caution of common man he turned he just
is very smooth it
turning uh an insult into a compliment
you know and a lot of that is just the
way preserves took it in the first place
yeah I agree they're both very good
talkers and they talk a lot and Tyrion
thinks about that how he just wants to
need the more illyrio talks and the more
he drinks he's
maybe more careful than the baron but he
does let a few things out that tyrion's
able to
get a sense of a lot of things Tyrion
figures out that this that they're up to
something he he figures out that that
Griff is more young Griff is more
important to him than he's letting on
which has led to all these Blackfire
theories and him being his father
and more suspicions about his connection
to Varys and all these other things that
help set up the Blackfire plot the young
Rift plot whatever you want to call it
and yeah that feels pretty similar here
yeah well you I mean you mentioned young
Griff I I think that illyrio illyrio has
this conspicuous fondness for the
handsome young boy young Griff which I
think is similar to how the baron
Vladimir has a conspicuous fondness for
the handsome young boy uh fade ralpha
and you know fade ralpha and young Griff
are both uh
talented well maybe not talented but but
they're both like young trained Warriors
and they both have a nice hair and they
both are Moody teenagers like fade
ralpha and young Griffin both like these
impetuous teenagers who have these sort
of temper tantrums and they sort of they
sort of are learning to be smart like
they they are being trained by their
villainous uh conspiratorial Mentor
they're being trained to be a political
player but they are not as good of a
political player like fade router is not
as good at scheming as the baron
Vladimir and young Griff is not as good
at scheming as lyrio and that's how
Tyrion is able to mess with young Griff
and convince him to go west and all of
that so um so you know I I don't I don't
I don't think that illyrio is like
um sexually interested in young Griff in
the way that the baron Vladimir is
sexually interested in fate ralpha but I
think there's definitely like a
similarity to their
um to their close relationship and that
sort of mentor of relationship ship and
and how young Griff and fade ralpha they
both I think are unworthy Scions you
know like the baron has invested all
this time and energy into putting fade
router into power and illyrio's put all
this time and energy into putting young
Griffin to power but we we can plainly
see that fade ralpha and young Griff are
both not worthy to be rulers because
they're not as good as the Alternatives
yeah yeah
so that's a great yeah that's a super
great Point yeah they both explore like
like the they both are manufactured
Heroes fade rather and younger if they
both have been carefully created and and
uh groomed to take power but that it
just doesn't it just isn't a good idea
you know the situation
ironically they they created the better
alternative through their actions by
sending them into situations where
they weren't uh expected to survive they
weren't like cuddled and protected all
throughout their whole lives even though
they were given a great education and
Varys goes on with that speech to Kevin
about how oh aegon has been scared he
knows what it's like to fix Nets and
swim in a river and do all these all
this like common born stuff and but
that's nothing next to what Danny has
gone through right Danny's gone through
way more than that Danny's gone through
legitimately feared for her life she was
sold as a slave she was you know taken
by a Dothraki call and
been to seen horrible things in war
already at a young age whereas young
Griff didn't see any of that and the
same with Paul Faye didn't see any of
those things he didn't go through like
true hardships he may have had tough
training sessions and sweat it out you
know a lot of calories while in the gym
you know I'm sure his muscles were large
but he wasn't like shaped by the desert
like Danny and Paul were and and fought
with the the fremin or with the Dothraki
which are a bit of a parallel here at
least at least in this particular
context where it's just really hard
living and it makes you tough if you
survive it and neither of them were
expected to survive and because they did
they're a better savior leader figure
than this engineered version that was
basically grown in a lab for you know if
you want to use that metaphor
yes there are that's the plan that's
being foisted here you have Baron who's
his Beast
a band to be a bad ruler that everybody
hates he's doing this on purpose in
order to later replace him with his
beloved engineered alternative and fade
which is exactly what illyrio and varas
are trying to do by sending viserys
leading to thracky to Westeros and then
have their guy come in and be the Savior
against that and thus come out ahead and
be beloved for his being such a hero so
it's it's super similar in that regard
of course uh and you know
obviously there's huge differences if we
were to sit here and list all the
differences there'd be huge differences
as well but these similarities are are
Stark and and crazy and cool I love it
yeah yeah no I yeah that that is a
similarity that is so specific that I
think it almost has to be George copying
Frank Erbert because yeah illyrio's
sending young Griff to replace all
viserys is this is the same goddamn idea
as the baron sending Fade to replace the
awful rebond it's it's the same plan and
it's such a specific plan
I love it love it yeah
so and of course there's I wonder if I
think illyrio is a witch from Rich from
whalfur but he does trade and you know
he did get rich from in that origin
stuff it's kind of similar he eats like
crazy and yeah yeah they both love food
and money and luxury and and that that
sort of indulgence is all uh yeah coding
for a sort of villainous Vibe
um
so yeah huge similarities
then they both are slavers
um illyrio slaves and the Hawkings have
slaves and so they both use and abuse
people and that's part of their villainy
and and yeah like it's that whole idea
of you know illyrio creating and
installing young Griff and Vladimir
installing fader Alpha it's that idea of
you can't manufacture true worthy
heroism you can't be born into true
worthy heroism you can only get it by
experience and work and intention and
hardship and that's what Paul and
Daenerys represent and that's how both
stories criticize monarchy and and
feudalism it's that idea that any kind
of power passed down through generations
is is just a deeply flawed system
um and so yeah even when the good guys
wielded yeah right like even they can't
uh can't avoid a lot of the problems
that come in here into the system
yeah you're not born into Power you have
to earn power and that's what the heroes
do in Perth stories
yeah that's part of John we didn't even
mention Jon Snow that's a big part of
him as well whether or not no matter how
his end goes he has gone through a lot
to
gain power or to have been placed over
other people to have the responsibility
of leadership he he first went through
legitimate dangers and survived
legitimate things and and suffered and a
lot of that so yeah uh Arya she's not
necessarily going to be a leader but
she's gone through a lot Anza is is
probably going to be a leader been
through a lot right and yeah it's it's a
recurring they're all going through
legitimate experience rather than
something that's that's cultured or done
buying closed doors
is someone in the live chat points out
that the second Dune book has a has a
quirky funny dwarf called The Jazz uh
which is similar to Tyrion is often
playing word games and being funny and
provocative I think there are some
similarities between the Jazz and Tyrion
um and it's a great point I'm surprised
I missed that yeah really obvious now
that you mention it yeah
and George has had several dwarf
characters I I remember the the authors
of the expanse Daniel Abraham and Ty
Frank were saying that George Martin
like the the expanse sci-fi story
started as a tabletop role-playing game
um with
Daniel and and George and others as
players and and George's character in
this role-playing game was a uh was a
dwarf character uh with a really
ridiculous name uh that I can't remember
off the top of my head but uh
but yeah dwarves that's amazing I knew
about the campaign stuff I didn't know
George's character was a dwarf though
that part's new to me that's great yeah
yeah George has a has a thing for dwarfs
apparently
anyway uh so shall we talk a little more
about Daenerys and Paul because they
both are these you know Scions of
ancient powerful houses who lose their
Birthright and they both wander the
desert and they both uh learn to survive
in a different environment and they
learn to live with locals that Dothraki
and the framing what what other
similarities are there
yeah this is a really strong one and
it's it's nicely led into from this this
plotting of before where we talked about
who the real hero figures are the ones
who have really had strong and tough
upbringings that's probably the most
overarching similarity between them is
that they are inheritors of
huge important bloodline at a really
hugely important time
and
they both have
prophetic Visions both have you said
they're going out into the desert and
survive that and out in the desert they
interact with and come to lead an
extremely powerful
uh local Regional group like the
Dothraki slash the fremin in this case
who are extremely formidable like the
fremin of course are a much much older
culture they're much more highly
developed the Dothraki are are more just
straightforward Warrior culture in its
in its first few hundred years or maybe
a little later it's kind of unclear when
they actually started but they
definitely aren't anywhere near as old
as the fremin
and though the Dothraki don't tame
you know dragons Daenerys does and
that's obviously a a parallel to the
shahelud and the riding of sand worms
which very few people do just like very
few people ride dragons in the history
of A Song of Ice and Fire
and
they both have a family member with them
when they're when they're going to Exile
of course Danny has an incompetent poor
uh influence on her in visares whereas
Paul has Jessica who is extremely
capable like the exact opposite of
viserys's level of competence and level
of education and mental fortitude and
everything I mean they're they're about
as opposite as it gets here yeah
um yeah including the and the pregnancy
part is similar too because you have
Paul being or Paul obviously isn't
pregnant but Jessica is and then Danny
is pregnant and it's both it's with
someone who is
uh with someone who was passed recently
within the story
yeah it's interesting that like Daenerys
I I think has this intense loneliness
because she's a Targaryen alone in the
world and as you say viserys is not a
good family man
um and and Paul in contrast Paul has his
mother by his side he has a family
member watching his back which is great
but but I guess Paul's isolation comes
more from his prescience and his visions
and all these experiences that are going
on in his head that um that that's sort
of what isolates Paul
um and yeah as you say they both have
these prophetic visions and the sense of
Destiny uh that drives them and there's
we can talk more about prescience later
but it's something that is both
empowering and and it's also dangerous
um
and there's also a question like you
know
part of the books is that Paul the way
the way Paul treats the foramen is
exploitative is is sort of part of the
point and and you know we can question
is it right the way that Daenerys uses
the Dothraki and that's something that I
guess we will see more of in the next
books
yeah and you're right because that is
obviously a huge question in for for
Paul and and just not just how he leads
the fremin but how he wields power in
general which will also be a question
with Daenerys and they both will have to
battle
uh
Messiah complexes like Danny is having
these thoughts about you know I'm lonely
I have all this power
need to be responsible with this power
but it can be overwhelming I mean she
we've seen her once or twice already
maybe loser temper and do something that
she probably shouldn't have done uh in
terms of morality her own morality it
would violate some you know things that
she has said previously she wouldn't do
or wouldn't want to do and that's the
thing you were we've been talking about
since the beginning the use of power and
this is where we're going to talk about
Paul and bran in a minute and this is
where those things diverge Danny did not
have
good examples of wielding Power Wheel
she had viserys and when she thinks of
her father that's the Mad King like
that's not a good example and it's it's
a good thing that she wasn't raised by
him but her one maybe decent example is
rhaegar who never actually was King and
she didn't know him
and yeah and then she's called Drogo
like she falls in love with this guy
kind of because like he he's
such a strong presence within her the
only strong presence within her world
the first person that like treated her
halfway decently even though he also
you know married a 13 year old or
whatever she was which is pretty sketchy
so that's the what just goes to show
what
um says good treatment in her world
whereas
bran when we talk about him that's
what's gonna be more similar to Polly
Paul had a pretty good upbringing he had
great education he was treated well and
he had a lot of people helping him learn
which is similar to more similar to bran
but we'll hold off on that for them for
the moment yeah yeah no that's a great
Point like Paul had every advantage and
every luxury and all the training and
knowledge in the world when he was
growing up whereas Daenerys had nothing
she basically grew up on the straights
um so I think Daenerys Daenerys had a
lot of obstacles and hardships that Paul
didn't Paul has advantages over her I
think there's another similarity in the
you know like Paul and the foramen and
like Daenerys and slavers Bay they both
are characters who come into these
foreign lands and these foreign cultures
and they tell they tell these foreign
cultures what to do Paul says Hey
Freeman you should follow me against
shaddam and not you should fight in the
weirding way and Daenerys comes to
Slaves Bay and she's like hey you guys
should stop slaving and you guys should
treat the people differently and she
tries to totally upend the social order
of this foreign culture
um and there's lots of like complicated
ideas about whether or not that's a good
idea both stories have been accused of
being a white savior story
um like I remember was it the end of
Game of Thrones season three when
Daenerys liberates uh astapor or is it
marine and there's that scene yeah the
crowd surfing scene yeah yeah Daenerys
surfs the crowds and it's like this very
like visually striking thing where all
of these like darker skinned people are
worshiping this white-skinned person who
has just come to save them and so and so
so both stories are being accused of
being a white savior story and you know
I I think the I think the point of June
is that it's about how Paul is a false
Messiah and it's about how it is a bad
idea and it is wrong how Paul exploits
the foramen whereas I think A Song of
Ice and Fire has not quite
um
that storyline has not concluded we
don't really know how Daenerys will
resolve the situation in slavers Bay and
I'm really curious how it will end like
will it end with you know slavers obey
is like wow thanks for fixing our
culture Daenerys you sure told us a
superior set of morals and cultural
norms to follow that's great that's sort
of what happens in the Game of Thrones
TV show where Daenerys inexplicably
leaves Dario bloody naharas in charge of
something and like
we're sort of meant to believe that
slavers Bay is fixed now and it's like
really
um Mario can take care of it don't you
worry yeah and you know and again like
George says he doesn't write allegory
but like there's obvious parallels to
you know Western invasions of the Middle
East and you know Afghanistan and Iraq
and some of those situations not turning
out so well so I'm really curious how
the Daenerys and slavers Bay story line
will resolve and whether it will turn
out to have been a good idea for
Daenerys to try to take over and reform
slavers Bay
yeah and that's something they
definitely have that that is
related to this is they both have
both a legal like they both been pushed
outside from their claim or their
rightful title they both also have a
supernatural
uh Destiny
um they're like a chosen one type figure
all uh the Paul's kind of an engineered
birth I
you know manipulation over a long period
of time trying to create the perfect
conditions or whatever and Danny it's
not quite that explicit but
she's the Mother of Dragons she's the
one that brought dragons back after all
this time and she had these Visions in
the first book of ancestors with pale
swords and encouraging her to wake the
dragon and all this stuff so
absolutely similar child of Destiny
stuff and that's why this Forks into
bran a bit because he also has a lot of
that as well as John so Paul is kind of
way Paul is kind of Danny bran and John
wrapped into one
with maybe even some of the other
characters maybe even some
maybe even some Sansa thrown in there
too I don't know it's hard to say but
there's a lot of these because some of
these things as we said at the beginning
they some of these are just common
tropes or features of stories that have
lots of politics and and big Power games
but some of them are pretty specific and
pretty detailed and uh yeah it's kind of
a challenge to suss these things out
yeah I mean it's funny we were talking
about how like young Griff and fade
ralpha are both like manufactured Heroes
and manufactured rulers and how that's
like not a good idea in the books but
it's true that you know Paul is the
product of this artificial breeding
program and he has been bred and trained
to be a leader like young Griff and
Daenerys you know she's the Targaryen
Heir and she
arguably may also have been the product
of a breeding program because it's not
explicit in the books but there are all
these hints about how you know many
targaryens were into prophecy like
viserys in House of the dragon and
there's all these hints that you know
the woods witch said that joharis and
and
um yeah and his wife should marry and
there's these hints about bloodraven may
have you know like like egg marrying a
Blackwood who have the old gods Northern
blood and like that you know that it's a
whole long speculative thing but there
are hints that the targaryens may be
following a certain prophesied bloodline
genetic breeding program in order to you
know keep the Dragon Blood to themselves
and also and also potentially to produce
the prince that was promised that hasn't
been revealed in the books but I think
that it is hinted at
um and so yeah you know so so in a way
Paul and Daenerys they are both
manufactured and artificially bred to be
saviors and heroes but the difference
between them and young Griff and fade
ralpha is that Paul and Daenerys also
have experience and they also have
struggle and they also have hardship on
top of being bred to be heroes and on
top of being born into these
um great Bloodlines so that they they
are a Confluence of like all all the
different kinds of power coming together
in one person uh for for good or for ill
because of course you know Paul Paul's
Ascension uh you know I won't totally
spoil it but Paul's Ascension turns out
to be maybe not great and uh daenerys's
Ascension at least in Game of Thrones
season eight turns out to be maybe not
great so
yeah it's a huge parallels the next bag
because obviously she helped save the
world from the white walkers but then
that other part
it doesn't go so well
Jackie C in the live chat asks if
perhaps the direwolf human Bond was also
engineered I don't know how much you
like these tinfoil theories as these but
I I do like the idea that the Starks in
some way deliberately acquired the
magical power to skin change and to walk
because there's all these bits in the
world book about how the Starks the
Starks took the daughters and this and
the stocks forcibly married the uh the
people who they conquered including the
uh the Warg King the Starks married the
daughters of the Warg king
um and perhaps it was marrying the the
family of the Warg King that gave the
Starks the Warg blood and the Warped
genes that allow them to have that power
and
um
you know if George was reading June and
you know George has written other
stories about genetic manipulation and
modification I I don't know if it'll
ever be acknowledged in the books but
but I think it is very reasonable to
think that the Starks deliberately
acquired Certain Magical genes just as
the targaryens have Certain Magical
genes I I mean Aziz you and ashaya
interviewed George Martin recently and
George Martin was telling you guys about
how you know yes like the reason why the
targaryens do incest is in order to keep
that dragon writing Gene to themselves
and it's part of a sort of eugenic
genetic plan so George definitely is
aware of and mind is thinking in that in
that way and um everyone should go and
check out the history of Westeros George
Martin interview if you haven't already
yeah thanks for the plug yeah that was a
really good interview we we got a lot of
time with him almost an hour and a half
and we've listened to enough interviews
with him that we knew when to like try
to stop him because he'll go off for
five minutes on something that maybe he
said in other interviews so we were
trying to steer him in the direction of
new things and one of the things that
came from that was him talking about how
it wasn't just the the dragon Lords that
did that it was also the blood magicians
of valyria that did that which makes
sense they're the ones that are fiddling
with the jeans in the first place to
make them permanent or to make them
Dragon bonded or to make them something
that's similar to skin changing or
whatever allows them to continuously
have the same genetic features maybe
some of that same magic exists in
Westeros uh we did some episodes on how
the houses that still have weirwood
trees seem to have stronger genetic
patterns than ones that don't so that
might be you know a way for George to
have sort of implanted that within his
world so yeah there's a lot of that in
both and it's a this is one that's also
a TR not a Trope but a fun feature of
fantasy and sci-fi maybe more fantasy
because in sci-fi it's more well you
engineer this you can change someone's
DNA that's more like a
in a Sci-Fi setting it can be almost ad
hoc but in a fantasy setting it has to
be a little mysterious and more like
underground a little more random a
little more uncertain and one that comes
to mind is Lovecraft his breeding of
people with developed ones or the rather
the Deep ones rather
um is was a recurring feature in some of
his stories where people would have that
within them and it would slowly manifest
and if
Madness slowly manifests in the
targaryens and they already have instead
of fish features they have dragon
features which we see manifested in some
of these children that come out horribly
wrong oh yeah I think it's wrong I think
it would be wrong to not be open to some
of these genetic manipulation
series uh without being too specific
about them yeah I mean where do the
Starks get that ability why did this
horrible tradition of first night
persist well maybe because they were
trying to spread this magical DNA around
to enough people or maybe that's why
people accepted it because they could
receive magical DNA and that that also
explains like the dragon seeds who
sometimes they consider themselves
blessed when a dragon lord would come
and sleep with them because they might
have a silver-haired child that well the
implication being it's more than just
the silver hair that matters there you
know so
yeah I think it's a there's obviously
this is a big part of Dune as well the
manipulation of Bloodlines the certain
families breeding with other families
the
certain things being right at the right
time I'm not as familiar with the doing
stuff I haven't read do nearly as many
times as Song of Ice and Fire but you
you feel filled that in all pretty well
already anyway so yeah the parallels are
very strong there uh
there's other there's other stories that
do this like The Witcher bloodline you
know chosen one all these these things
come out
and a lot of different stories but I
think both of these stories do it
particularly well they use they invert
the Trope then it's not just chosen one
hero win it's no there's problems with
being the chosen one oh like what does
this do to you Lord Lord of the Rings
has that in a sense with
uh Frodo isn't a supernatural being but
having held on to the one ring for so
long messes that dude up right and
that's somewhat directly Supernatural
but it's meant to also be metaphorical
uh because it messed up everyone who
held it yeah
yeah it all comes down to power I think
like like the political power the
magical power the prophetic destined
power it's it's all different ways of
looking at how does power affect people
and how does you know the the act of
striving to get what you want how does
that change you and and uh what what is
the cost I think that's a big part of it
um so while we're talking about you know
Daenerys with the Dothraki and and Paul
with the framing uh there's a lot of
similarities uh I think with uh Jon
Snow's relationship with the wildlings
and daenerys's relationship with the
foramen
uh because the Forman uh the foramen are
are the free people who are outside the
control of the realm and the the
wildlings call themselves The free folk
they are outside the control of of
Westeros and they both are
underestimated by the powers that be
there's there's some really similar
passages where the baron Vladimir and
the emperor they think that there's
barely any fremin just like a few
Renegades at the at the edge of the
desert whereas in reality there's
millions of fremin all through the
planet and and similarly there's a
moment in book three where Tywin says no
there can't be lots of wildlings like
the Lands Beyond the Wall cannot support
vast numbers of wildlings when in
reality you know a hundred thousand
wildlings turn up at the wall later on
and and so um they both of these they're
both of these underestimated
um cultures who exist in these extreme
climates and have adapted to these
extreme environments
um and turn out to be a force far
greater than anyone expected
uh that is is a kind of a speaks to how
George writes his story in one of the
major comparisons of it to a lot of
other stories whether it's doing or
otherwise he takes he takes these things
and he layers them like Paul had all
these things wrapped into one character
where as we just talked about how a lot
of these features are spread out between
bran John and Danny
in some cases they're doubled like you
just said the fremin are paralleled in
both the Dothraki and in the free folk
and there's elements to them in both and
the what how they learn how they learn
to lead the lessons they they learn as
compared to the lessons of their home
culture and how they have to square
those two is really important like
everything Paul has grown up with a lot
of it's thrown out the door when he
meets the fremin but on the other hand
some of those things line up pretty well
and he's able to
win them over using some of those things
but also he just has you know they he
the setup for him you know they are
quoting scripture that you know shows
his arrival is coming and they're like
oh this is a chosen this is the person
we've expected so which is that I guess
speaks to the the vast amount of
groundwork laid for ball before he he
took the reins before he was even born
but also before he took the reins of
power and for Danny those things were
there too they just weren't laid out for
her they were laid out but she took them
they were a part of her family but she
was an afterthought in illyrio's plan
until
she wasn't until she proved she was they
were like oops actually she hatched she
did what now she hatched dragon eggs
okay let's let's work her into the plan
you know but she wasn't part of it
initially and uh that might be that's
kind of what John is John was an
afterthought to a lot of the main
characters he's not important he's this
kid on the wall right he was the the
bastard son that was the least important
of the Starks obviously as a reader you
don't necessarily see it that way but
within his the the
lens of his Society that's he's sent to
the wall when he's 15. I mean that's
that's clearly a child you don't expect
to have a big future but obviously
uh that's not how it goes at all he has
a huge feature and that's the similarity
between bran and uh or Paul and Danny
they accepted John wasn't expected to
die though he was believed dead in the
context of being lost Beyond the Wall uh
so
of course there's a couple times that
happens actually but John's believed
dead a couple times and now currently
we're waiting on uh him being stabbed
and whether he's going to get back up so
yes
yeah that one keeps coming
yeah it's yeah I mean we were talking
about how you know Paul and Daenerys are
both sort of
manufactured Heroes and they come from
like a a plan like you know illyrio and
Varys were planning to use Daenerys in
the in their play for the throne and the
benef we're planning to use Paul with
the breeding program but but both of
them they benefit from that plan but
they go off the plan and they defy the
schemas who wanted to manipulate them
um and I guess this is sort of mild
spoilers for the first dune book but you
know Paul Paul defies the bandage Ezra
and he goes against their their wishes
and their expectations and I think in a
similar way Daenerys defies the
expectations of Varys and illyrio with
the dragons and and her plans for
Westeros so so it's about defying the
scheme isn't defying the plan and
choosing your own path for better or
worse and that's you know with the
foramen and
um the free folk and the Dothraki like
these are both these great armies that
the heroes
um adopt control over uh and they use
these armies uh potentially to take over
the realm and and in all these cases
there's an implication that it might not
be such a good idea to do so because you
know without spoiling too much the
fremens influence on the universe is
maybe not good and you know John in his
chapters thinks a lot about how you know
I want to let the wildlings through the
wall but
if I do that there will be thousands of
wildling Raiders who might want to raid
the North and burn the North and steal
stuff and kill people and and similarly
the Dothraki Daenerys worries that the
Dothraki could cause chaos in Westeros
so you know the Freeman and the and the
wildlings and the Dothraki are all these
powerful tools but who can't but but who
may cause as much damage as as good
um so there's a lot of danger and
complexity there I also like how you
know each of these cultures has a strong
male leader who is
respectable in certain ways but who the
hero screws over so like the leader of
the framing in June is still go and
stillgar is this really
impressive smart thoughtful capable
powerful guy and you know I guess mild
spoilers but you know stilgar stillga
gets
he becomes less and he is reduced
through his relationship with Paul he
becomes a follower
um and and he becomes less of like his
own man as a result of Paul and
there's a tragedy to that and I think in
a similar way like John sort of
supplants Mance Raider you know Mance
Raider John likes man's Raider and and
Mance is almost like a father figure to
John almost like how stilgar is is a
little bit of a father figure to Paul
um and yet John inadvertently causes
Mance Raiders downfall he is still alive
in the books but you know Mance Raider
is much humbled by Jon
um and I think the other parallel is is
Drogo Karl Drogo is the leader of the
Dothraki and I think he Drogo is less
admirable than
um men's and Stilger but there is still
a kind of tragedy in that Drogo you know
is beloved at least by Daenerys and yet
daenerys's actions cause drogo's
downfall
um Daenerys tries to save droga from you
know that infected wound but you know
Miriam Mazda
her influence may possibly have caused
drogo's death or at least you know
daenerys's daenerys's involvement in you
know Drogo being turned into a catatonic
zombie and you know it's Daenerys who
puts the pillow on drogo's head so so in
all of these cases the hero causes the
downfall of a at least semi-likable
um leader and and there's there's
something messed up about all of those
yeah even if they're not likable like
you say they're not like a good person
like Drogo is not a good person but you
still you're still find yourself curious
what he's gonna do wanted to see
him actually invade well like a lot of
us wanted to see what happened if he
invaded Westeros I'm like how is that
going to go like these are real people
you know I'm not I'm not wishing real
suffering on the world I want to see
what happens if this dude invades West I
remember a good friend of mine was like
reading the books it was like I can't
wait to see what Khal Drogo does when he
gets to Westeros and I'm like
you know this was like 10 years ago but
so funny stuff like that but yeah you're
right like that's a similar thing like
it goes to the same power theme that we
keep coming back to urge talks about it
in terms of magic using a metaphor that
I like which is
sorcery is like a sword without a hilt
and these or like peoples that you lead
to Victory against an important opponent
only to have what do you do with them
afterwards is that same kind of thing
the Dothraki are a sword without a hilt
The freminar Sword without a hilt once
they're once they have a certain amount
of power or reach or whatever uh then
yeah they're they're you can't put that
sword back in the Scabbard afterwards
and that's uh yeah that's a definite
strong power theme between these two uh
stories there's an interesting line in
in melisandre's pay of a chapter where
she thinks that she's she's sort of
pretending to be helping the wildlings
in mancerata but internally Melisandre
thinks yeah these wildlings are doomed
the free folk dance Raider is doomed
they will go extinct there's no helping
them and it's like this really dark like
messed up thing that you know Melisandre
and the characters are using the free
folk but Melisandre expects they're
doomed and you know
moderate I suppose spoilers for
book four of Dune but you know the the
framing we learn are also a doomed
people because ultimately their culture
does basically go extinct and they
become this pathetic Museum fremin
culture and you know they lose their
original lifestyle and you know I think
that I think that's I think that is
inevitable for the wildlings in A Song
of Ice and Fire because you know the
wildlings
have mostly already been killed by the
White Walkers I think and you know like
the and they've broken against the wall
and they're having to leave their
Homeland and you know if even if the
wildlings survive I I I'm not sure the
wildlings Will Survive Beyond the Wall
which I think if they're not existing
and living in their
in the natural environment in the in the
place that their culture is based on can
their culture survive you know so so I
see a lot of similarities there with the
wild things and the Furman
it's a great one because it's it's also
succinctly said by another character in
the same parallel we're making which is
with Mary mazdoor
she mocks Danny when Danny's like hey I
saved your life and she's like not
really
you say you literally saved my life but
everyone I knew and loved in my home all
those things are gone like what is my my
life sucks now I don't even really want
to be alive like I kind of would rather
be dead I wish I died with everybody
else you know I have nothing now yeah
and that's this that's a similar thing
you know with these like if the
wildlings aren't
free if they're not living the way they
lived then yeah they are they might
still be alive but they're no longer
wildlings it's not as harsh as Mary
mazdoor
um more gradual thing right it'd be
something that plays out over
Generations like like you say it does
with the fremin
it's the same fate for those people it's
it's a way of life that that dies with
the events of the story or starts to die
that you see that that uh Boulder start
to roll downhill even if it takes a
while to get to the bottom
yeah that's a great point about Miriam
Mazda because yeah we were wandering
earlier if you know A Song of Ice and
Fire ever will sort of you know question
more
um daenerys's savior role with slaves
Bay and everything yeah I guess even
from book one
The Song of Ice and Fire books have said
hey Daenerys like when you try and come
in and save these other cultures uh
sometimes it's not as simple as you
think and sometimes you're not being as
helpful as you think you are and yeah
Miriam Mazda is a really really strong
um point in that direction for sure
yeah they make it clear and I think Dune
does this as well by showing you have
well when it's an obvious brutal enemy
your choices are simpler but you
it can still lead to harm later like
Danny it's going to be very
straightforward like yeah well Dothraki
you're bad but they're not as bad as the
others killing everyone literally wiping
them all out and so that's the that's
part of the conundrum
but
you also have this
ground of
um
well you can't just leave those people
behind either like the Dothraki those
are
you know you don't it's wrong to wipe
them out entirely and with slavers Bay
the example is okay well George made it
the worst possible people you could and
just show that even if you're trying to
reform a culture that absolutely
definitely is evil like there's no doubt
slavers Bay like he he goes so far as to
have them have hairstyles of horns right
they shape their hair into horns like
this lit it's it's hell like it's meant
to remind you of Western Christian
versions of Hell there's
people living in an extreme heat with
constant endless brutality
and the people inflicting this are Ultra
rich people with horns you know
the fours are really strong so you have
uh
uh like that to
if you can't fix that if the moral
question isn't whether you should fix
that it's how do you fix that right yeah
and if you can't even fix that then how
do you do how do you handle these much
more nuanced situations how do you like
it's right the emperor is trying to kill
your family you it's fair for you to
stop him
let's look at all you're also affecting
the entire galaxy or the entire known
human Galaxy
yeah yeah I think you're right that like
George makes the cultures of slavers Bay
cartoonishly evil so that we can ask you
know if Daenerys if Daenerys can't
reform these cartoonishly evil slavers
who literally eat puppies without
creating without creating like a moral
Quagmire then how on Earth can Daenerys
hope to take over Westeros without
creating a similar mess of of of moral
complications so so yeah I think that's
what he's got
it's maybe getting a little too deep
into just Danny specifically but like
look who her advisors are she's got like
she's gonna have like makoro and Tyrion
and Dora maybe if he's allowed not like
the tatted Prince outstanding people
standard Prince yeah like these are her
people giving her advice like uh Brown
Band Plum you know like she knows these
aren't good people necessarily but still
this is who's telling her things you
know Kirsten is a good man but he's not
like Savvy enough to give her advice on
these trickier issues anyway and and he
might not be around much longer
yeah compared to Paul who has like the
most over-the-top like virtuous wise
people you know the best of the best are
his advisors and daenerys's advisors are
the worst of the worst
yeah it's a it's a really interesting
dichotomy day that George lays out early
on with the the type of education that
the different people are getting in
their their environment their nature
nature versus nurture versus
well just those two yeah I was going to
add a third but that's enough so part of
the horror of slavers Bay is of course
the unsullied who are these children who
are forced to kill puppies and who are
castrated and made into Unix and used as
slave soldiers and um and we think there
are some similarities between the
unsullied and the sardica huh
I'd say so because yeah they're both
friend from
very young age if not birth uh
uh and they're born into an environment
there's absolutely no escape from and
that you you must turn into this thing
that they're making you become it's a
lot like
well it's definitely slavery in the
unsullied case even even you know
accepting maybe after Danny's freed them
and with the starter car they're
basically a slave Army right like it's
not quite that simple I don't think
they've got a retirement plan no
[Laughter]
and they're pretty
incredibly tough like they're really
hard to beat their their perhaps the
toughest thing there is they're uh in
their world although
um
yeah this article are obviously tested
by the fremin that's the ongoing thing
and uh the unsullied we'll have to see
what happens with them you know how they
stand up to
memories of the dead or whatever else
they face not quite sure about that yet
but seems like that'll be
even though they're not necessarily
murderous
you know raping Savages or whatever you
want to call what's going to be left
behind they still something still has to
be done with them they still have to
have lives after the fact and they may
be rather than a danger to society
Society might be a danger to them
because everyone's gonna you know they
might be shunned they might not be
accepted they might and they I don't
know it's uh
Westeros isn't going to be a kind place
to them even if they're
um
heroic even if their actions are
important and I don't know that they'll
be treated well might be like a another
opportunity for allegory after the facts
uh the veterans not being treated well
you know by the population that
that uh was benefited from their service
greyworm will simply start his own Noble
House Aziz just like him
easy solution
I I think that um like yeah like the the
unsullied themselves are not necessarily
cruel Warriors in the way that the
sadakara are but the creation of the
unsullied is unbelievably cruel and I
think that that cruelty is meant uh
meant to reflect on the society that
creates them like the cruelty of this
article shows how bad and unjust the
Carino Empire is and the cruelty of the
unsullied creation shows how cruel and
unjust asterobor and slavers Bay is so
in both cases it sort of justifies those
regimes being overthrown
I think
um I also think there's similarities
between the sardica and the kingsguard
because the sadaka are like the Imperial
loyalist uh best warriors who who serve
the emperor and the kingsguard are the
supposedly the best warriors who are
most loyal to the king's God but uh of
course we learned that you know King's
God are sometimes not loyal and they are
corrupt and they're sometimes not even
very good Warriors like boros blonde uh
and similarly the Sada car we are told
uh have become weaker because they're
corrupt and they're arrogant and they're
no longer as powerful as they used to be
so so the kingsguard and the sadaka both
represent like the degradation and the
corruption of their of their uh regimes
yeah that's a great point you you see
the kingsguard the early one and it's
something that's spoken of
in the books at several places by
several characters of how great the
kingsguard used to be even in Aries time
and it's debatable whether those guys
were actually great morally but they
were definitely great warriors and yeah
like in the current times yeah these
guys are
a mixture of
horrible people and just incompetent
people and people who don't belong like
Jamie
uh so even though he was he doesn't
belong for a couple of reasons possibly
but
either way yeah it the the parallel is
very strong even though the kingsguard
is a much smaller order and the the
knights watch isn't maybe as corrupt but
it is another example of something that
that
an institution that fell apart over time
and that's causing big problems in the
story I mean they're assassinating their
own leader that's not a good so what
you're supposed to do it's not a good
score did that too yeah both the Kings
guard and the Knights watch have killed
their own leader in the in the story you
know yeah yeah the the rough in the
institutions represents the rot in the
regime
yeah and you see these things within
some of these other organizations and
that's how that's a recurring theme with
someone like Ned who leaves a legacy of
people wanting to be like him because he
did good things and that's a positive
inspiration versus the the exam prior
example of someone like Tywin
who inspired the opposite and then we
have the same with like a baron harkinen
who
he's worried about his own
Emily killing him right yeah and tywin's
own family does kill him you know
yeah great point
yeah it's uh yeah it's not only like
institutional corruption it's it's
families uh dysfunctional you know like
the Carino family is so messed up and
dysfunctional in the Lannister family is
so messed up into functional and so are
the targaryens I mean you know that they
I mean even the stocks I mean all of the
families are dysfunctional in their own
little ways even the Atreides like you
know the sort of tension with with lato
and Jessica and Jessica's resentment
that later never married Jessica you
know like I mean it's like it's like
what is it that um that quote about how
you know happy families are all the same
but unhappy unhappy families are all
unique and interesting
um that there are no perfect happy
families in Westeros or if there are
George Martin isn't writing about them
yeah they're they're not very fun let's
leave them alone I always think that's
what's happening on the arbor like
except for now that you're on ships are
hitting there I'm like where where is
the best place to be like deep in Inland
at the arbor the ironborn can't get to
just have wine and it's warm the winter
is definitely not going to get down
there you know yeah maybe maybe I don't
know where that would be in Dune either
yeah yeah maybe maybe the house Poland
or something is is having a perfectly
happy idyllic life Wow all of the messed
up families are all fighting for power
I'd like to uh respond to some super
chats and then I'd like to move on to a
slightly more spoilery uh Zone as we
start to talk more about some of the
later uh in-game book type stuff so
thank you for the Super Chat from Isaac
who says what do you think are the
themes that June and A Song of Ice and
Fire both explore the most and how does
it compare
I mean we've talked a lot about power
haven't we they both obviously are
stories about power and their stories
about heroism and questioning heroism
and how power changes people
um it's also about like prescience and
plans and prophecies and uh and the
dangers of those things and we're going
to talk about those things in depth soon
thanks for the Super Chat from uh
gladys's bastard son glidus Pike who
says do you think that June part two
will be any good what do you reckon as
these
I think so I mean part one was pretty
darn solid I mean I enjoyed it a lot and
I think there's no reason not to think
part two will be pretty good at least if
not better than pretty good so I'm
pretty optimistic yet I'm not usually
that optimistic these days there's so
many
if it was the first movie
I I wouldn't have been so sure but now
that they've done a good job with the
with the first movie I have more
confidence in the second one um so yeah
what about you
yeah I'm hopeful I I noticed that at
least from the trailers it looks like
June part two will be different from the
books much more than June part one was
June part one was pretty faithful to the
book so just cut out a few things
whereas June part 2 seems to be
introducing whole new plot lines that
weren't in the books at all including
involving like erilan and shaddam and
riskier yeah it's riskier like those
things could be improvements but I hope
that they don't you know mess with the
art of what makes the books good
um I think that Danny villeneuve's
intentions are good and I think that he
wants to capture what the books are
about so so fingers crossed
indeed thanks for the Super Chat from
film cram who says are you suggesting
that like the quizets how to Rack
prophecy or like the missing area
productiva the Azora High prophecy has
been implanted in its variations across
the world artificially to prep for the
white walkers attacking
well there is that thing in in House of
the Dragon which apparently George
Martin uh suggested about how aegon the
Conqueror may have had a vision and
conquered Westeros in order to protect
Westeros from the White Walkers and
avert the apocalypse and
um there's the implication that you know
viserys
um believed in that prophecy and and
passed that prophecy down and
um you know Blood Ravens manipulations
and I I think we can there certainly is
evidence in the books that the
targaryens were consciously preparing
for the white walkers to appear and um
and what is a prophecy if not a warning
you know what is a prophecy if not
someone from the past saying hey this is
going to be a problem you should prepare
for it
yeah that's certainly a big theory
around Kuwait as well whether she's part
of some manipulation and manipulation
doesn't have to mean negative like there
they have some goal of profit or
ambition it can mean we need to
manipulate this person into saving the
world you know or into putting her on
the right path to doing what needs to be
done it's not about personal benefit
it's about making sure everyone survives
or making sure this thread is met
properly and without any interference so
yeah I think there's definitely room I
mean it's outright said that you can go
into someone's dreams with glass candles
George already made it possible in his
world in at least one way
so yeah dream manipulation or
implanting a prophecy
which these are different things but you
know they're related uh they're there
yeah the Azora High prophecy is super
old the prince that was promised
prophecy is perhaps a different variant
or just a different name for the same
thing and that's been around a long time
and it's come up in multiple places you
got characters talking about it
uh in a lot of like Eamon talking about
it it relates to rhaegar it relates to
blood Raven yeah it's just we're just
not there yet with all all of the
reveals but it feels like it's going to
involve some of those same mechanisms of
manipulating the truth uh but maybe for
good reasons and and or just reading
what's coming you know the prophet it
could be more straightforward than we
think in some ways it's just the way
George is kind of revealing it more
slowly but either way you have the same
this kind of uh yeah this parallel it
works either way yeah it's interesting
that in both June and A Song of Ice and
Fire like prophecies are not things that
just exist naturally and automatically
and immutably and they just are what
they are and they just are the truth
prophecies in A Song of Ice and Fire are
made by people who have motivations and
you know we see how Melisandre
interprets and misinterprets her
prophecies based on her own biases and
we see how like visions and dreams are
not not just something that happened
naturally but can be planted as you say
like quaint with glass candles enters
daenerys's mind and gives her certain
messages for her own reasons and
bloodraven enters the minds of certain
characters like jojun and bran in order
to manipulate them and so so prophecies
are not just this inherent magical thing
that they are just another form of power
and of manipulation
um so I so I don't think as long as fire
goes as far as Frank Herbert did with
the missionaria protectiva wherein in
entire like religions are created
artificially over thousands of years
deliberately by the Benny Jesuit
um but it's not unreasonable to
speculate because yeah it is suspicious
that all over the world of Ice and Fire
there are all these suspiciously similar
prophecies about the prince that was
promised in Azor ahai and hakun the hero
and um and the last hero and and you
know you have to wonder are these are
these like natural memories of the past
or are they planted myths and planted
messages with the purpose of telling
people how to defeat the white walkers
when they come again how to create
lightbringer how to sacrifice an
illnessa
um how to use how to create Dragon steel
or you know whatever the secret is
yeah yeah
one we haven't even mentioned yet we
mentioned how Danny will bring unsullied
and Dothraki
she's also going to bring
lore worshipers they are
been told that she's savior of mankind
narrow the high priest of red temple in
volantis the largest one is openly
preaching that when we see Tyrion and
Jorah pass by so
that's a big part of the religious
aspect that we haven't really seen fully
play out yet where we're seeing the we
are seeing the seven and the High
Sparrow and that stuff just get started
in the books and we we maybe have some
idea where that's going to go based on
the show but the show didn't bring in
these hordes of velorists they just had
one they just had melisandra and your
thorus was there too I guess but he
wasn't really a zealot so that's going
to be a I think that's something that
goes under the radar because it wasn't
in the show but I think uh we're gonna
see that is something else Daenerys is
going to bring which will also cause
which will help perhaps defeat the
others but also perhaps create some
conflict out like what are they going to
do with all these like zealous fire
worshipers in a realm of seven
worshipers and that's similar to some
things that happen in Dune with belief
and and the the people getting a little
too into Paul and who he is and and uh
that message going too far and and
things that you were alluding to earlier
let's not forget fan favorite character
kinvara who had such a huge impact on
the story
yeah Daenerys is suddenly playing with
fire very very literally with the
rolloric uh priests and volantis and all
of that and uh and again I think that's
similar to like the religious fervor of
the foramen behind Paul we see religion
as a as a dangerous powerful force that
can get stuff done but it also is hard
to control and it um and Fire Burns
thanks for the Super Chat from chug who
says that uh Jon Snow will be God
emperor of Westeros thank you Lucifer
hey Lucifer morgenster who says thank
you big fan thank you Nazar who says
something weird about George Martin
thank you Sean who says thanks alt you
got me into reading June I'm on to
Heretics now and they've easily been the
best books I've ever read what's your
favorite movie
wow
um yeah well Heretics is is fun a lot of
people don't like Heretics in Chapter
House as much as the earlier books but
uh I think they've all got a lot of fun
unique stuff going on what is my
favorite movie oh my God Aziz can you go
first I try to think what my favorite
movie is
well I'm going to take a an easy way out
and just say the one I've seen the most
which is Monty Python and the meaning of
life
fantastic choice absurd amount of times
when I was younger I had it like you
know and I I I'm old enough to have had
a vcr and only a few tapes and that was
one of the few I had so I would play my
online uh computer role-playing games
while just putting that movie on repeat
so I'll go with that yeah fantastic
um I I've got to say I've seen The Blues
Brothers a lot of times oh good one
that's a good film
um I also really like the Royal
Tenenbaums I think I have a very basic
movie taste like I'm a real basic
when it comes to movies so I'm a fan of
Wes Anderson for sure
I can't believe you said the Royal
Tanner bombs because that is the first
movie ashaya and I watched together oh
really fantastic yep
thanks for the Super Chat from Jordan
who says Dune character alignment chart
yeah I I saw that that
um notorious repscally and ALT schwift X
did some um character alignment streams
with glidus ranking characters on how uh
how uh chaotic or orderly or and good
and evil they are the Dungeons and
Dragons alignment system which is fine
it would be interesting to do that with
June characters because June characters
morality is so
fraught and complicated
to rank them wouldn't it
yes
yeah how I don't geez what would Paul
even be what would at least rank him is
he yeah through neutral pole exists on
every point on the morality Spectrum
simultaneously he is uh and don't even
get us started on like God Emperor later
the second my goodness
because he like he like enforces order
for the sake of chaos and evil for the
sake of good oh yeah
uh thanks for the Super Chat from film
Comics explained who says the mystery of
life isn't a problem to solve but a
reality to experience which is one of
the great Dune quotes and he says thanks
for providing the best detailed analysis
on YouTube for both June and Game of
Thrones that has helped us all
understand our experiences with our
favorite IP cheers
thank you so much niet and uh check out
nietz channel film Comics explained
thank you Moss who says thank you for
helping me stay connected to my friend
who passed away last year he loved your
videos keep up the great work
thank you Moss sorry to hear about your
friend
thanks for the Super Chat from Zachary
who says any news on the Jon Snow video
the June Iceberg Maura love all
your work your takes are witty and
Illuminating
uh yeah uh I am making a Jon Snow video
for alt shift X it will probably be the
biggest alt shift x video ever I think
it will be somewhere between 90 minutes
and two hours long uh it's a detailed
examination of Jon Snow's story
um how it differs to the TV show where
it might go in future books I'm really
excited about it the video is mostly
done
um it will still take some time to
complete but I'm really excited about it
and uh I I think it will be the next old
shift x video that comes out so um so
yeah that that is that is coming
and thank you for the Super Chat from
nuisance who says I think there's
parallels between Melisandre and Jessica
as pseudo prophets who are in on the
facade I like the position facilitating
a fervent movement that puts them in
resulting isolation
yeah what do you think of that as Ace
that's pretty clever yeah because
Melisandre obviously knows she's making
some things up and she's using you know
changing some details to
push things in a direction that she
thinks is correct and yeah and Jessica
also is
we see her get in trouble with the uh
benad Jester because she does some
things her own way and is already kind
of a bit of a rogue melisandre's like
connection to the red Temple and like
who sent her it doesn't seem clear which
kind of leads us to believe and I think
reasonably so that she's also a bit of a
rogue and doing some things outside of
what the higher-ups or hierarchy the the
people that have wield power within the
the red Temple would have done it so
yeah that's a really good catch I like
that yeah I think there's a suspect
Martin where George did allegedly
confirmed that like yeah Melisandre is
she went to Stannis and Dragonstone on
her own accord and she's not operating
under the orders of a red Temple she
she's sort of a renegade Red Priest
which is really similar to how Jessica
is like a renegade Benny Jesuit who is
deviating from from their plan and yeah
like in that scene with Mapes where
Jessica sort of lies and manipulates to
fit the prophecy
um of the listening with Mapes that is
really similar to a lot of what
Melisandre does when we see Melisandre
um Melisandre describes towers by the
Sea crumbling under a great wave or
whatever and Jon Snow is like oh is that
eastwatch and Melisandre is like oh yeah
that definitely is eastwatch but inside
her thoughts we see Melissa going oh I
have no idea if that's Easter watch I
don't think that actually but yeah Jon
seems to think so so I'll go with her so
and that's really similar to when when
Jessica is like oh the maker yeah I
totally knew that the maker is a sand
worm yeah I know what a Chris knife is
so so both Melisandre and Jessica
totally Bluff in a hilarious way they
they cold read almost Mapes and John
respectively so um so yeah I think I
think that's a fantastic Point uh
nuisance
um thanks for the super jet from Isaac
who says rewatched your hooded man video
recently who's your favorite character
in the north at the end of dance I think
that I think that Wyman Mandalay is
enormously fun because Wyman
um is funny and evil and sort of heroic
all at the same time like Wyman has the
speech about the north remembers and how
he wants to avenge his son who was
killed at the Red Wedding and he gets
revenge on the phrase by cooking phrase
into pie and feeding them to their
family and he sort of wants to help
restore the Starks and he wants to save
rickon but really he's doing it for his
own political empowerment and he wants
to make he wants to take over the
hornwood lands and like Wyman has so
many layers on motivations and is so
much fun and it's so witty and fun to
read and um so yeah he's one of my faves
what about you Aziz
that does make some sense especially if
you paired with what you said before
about how the
real Baron is in the books like how he's
a little more
almost goofy jokey and and talkative and
Wyman manderly is
very talkative and he likes to he he's
gotten in trouble a little bit with uh
the things he's said even so
yep I like it I can see that for sure
thanks for the Super Chat from glidus
who says can you make a video about how
Curious George is different in the books
versus the TV show yeah look I mean it's
hard to I thought you did that already
I have been thinking of an April Fool's
joke explaining uh bionicle's law
I I think it would be really funny to go
real deep into uh all of that if anyone
remembers what Bionicles are but uh yeah
there's no limit to the ridiculous
topics we can cover uh on an April
Fool's video
seriously though I
I stand for the slander against the
Curious George show which is a faithful
adaptation
actually I have not seen the show
if have you done any like straight up
joke videos on history of Westeros
he did once
we did the written wisdom of Stannis
Baratheon a long time ago
and it was just like reading his quotes
and and just like setting up some of the
funny things he said and showing how
funny he is he's we we cited him as I
think the third funniest character in a
song of I swear there's Tyrion and
Dollar's Ed I think are probably ahead
of him but then it's just makes a strong
case he's he's damn funny not all the
sarcasm and jokes about Robert and all
that yeah yeah Stannis was robbed by The
Game of Thrones TV show that he has so
many funny lines in the books that were
just not included in the show which is
tragic
yes a real crit a real tragedy
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Dylan
who says do the Bionicle video on
ironically yeah well look I guess I
guess we have to do it now uh all right
I think we will now move into a slightly
more spoilery Zone
um which means we will talk about like
the ending of June book one and we'll
also move into some stuff that happens
in June book four but personally I don't
think people should worry all that much
about Dune spoilers because like the
June books spoil themselves with the
little quotes at the start of each
chapter and it's about prescience and
but yeah like if you're super worried
about June spoilers we will talk about
some June spoilers from now on
uh
who should we cover first Aziz do you
want to talk about uh Bran or John or
are you and Alia what are you feeling
yeah let's let's wrap up some of those
ones because those are kind of
continuations of things we had already
started talking about I think one of the
interesting things about John is he's
sort of an accidental
example of what Paul is engineered to be
whereas he's a combination of Bloodlines
whereas John just kind of accidentally
ended up as a child of Ice and Fire I
wasn't necessarily uh it wasn't
necessarily the result of years of
breeding but it was you know
uh rhaegar had a plan he wanted to have
the three children and he thought he was
following in some
prophesied thing but uh
it's not clear exactly what he was doing
you know he certainly said he his is the
Song of Ice and Fire you know from
Danny's Vision we see that and uh
that is
apparently being said to his firstborn
son the one that's killed but then he's
who he's wrong about so so this stuff is
a little more murky in A Song of Ice and
Fire but the things are all there all
these like people trying to have a child
of certain Bloodlines combining certain
Bloodlines and being for reasons laid
out long before
and there's some of that with bran too
except that he's he's maybe the real
maybe more a better example of something
that just happened
even though you appointed to some
examples of the Starks capturing magical
Bloodlines in the past and maybe that's
why they have
worg blood now that wasn't that it's
hard to argue that with some sort of
engineering thing where they were like
specifically trying to acquire that
because of
they probably did it because it was
power not because of they need they had
some goal from the for their descendants
which is possible for or at least
spelled out for aegon
so yeah the
brand is more like
the thing with blood Raven and looking
for who the next Green Seer is like who
is born amongst this population that has
the right traits so George did both
things where some people are born with
the traits and emerge whereas other ones
are are
engineered-ish and that goes to what we
were saying before about how he likes to
pack in multiple variations on these
core fantasy sci-fi ideas
yeah yeah that yeah magic power comes to
them through different angles Brand's
more of a homegrown natural green sear
whereas John is is a deliberate result
of rhaegar trying to unite ice and fire
it seems I I tend I tend to think that
rhaegar probably got a vision from
bloodraven
um saying hey rhaegar like you should
marry a stark to unite ice and fire and
fulfill the prophecy
um because that's what's so funny about
all the prophecy stuff like Amon talks
about you know how he and rhaegar were
interested in Prophecy and
um and you know jahiris and and I think
Aries the first probably as well
um but we never get direct
acknowledgment that bloodraven himself
was interested in Prophecy I think it
must be true because it makes all of his
actions make sense but it's so funny
that you know there's no mention of like
bloodraven trying to communicate with
aemon
um
despite bloodraven's interest in
Prophecy and aemon's interest in
Prophecy it's like I don't know it's so
puzzling and it makes me wonder if like
the old gods and the and the Wayward
connection to bloodraven might
alter his behavior or might alienate him
from the from the other targaryens
bloodraven is such an interesting
character
but obviously I think we've mentioned
you know the obvious similarities
between Paul and John both as these you
know lost Scions and uh both of them
have a bloodline Revelation so spoiler
for June book one uh but Paul finds out
that his mother Jessica is the daughter
of the baron Vladimir harkinen so Paul
finds out that he is partly a hakanan as
well as a trades and that's similar to
how John will eventually find out that
he is the son of a Targaryen as well as
a stark so you know both Paul and John
they have both the the ice and the fire
the two opposite families are united in
one in the hero
so that's interesting
um and they both yeah and bloodray
himself is that thing too he was a
United sort of of old gods family in a
and a Targaryen father so it's kind of
passing down that Legacy or continuing
that Legacy in a sense that also speaks
to before what we said about the
possibility that there's going to be
Secrets Revealed about maybe
history of the Starks there may be some
some boogeyman hiding in their ancestry
as well that maybe fits this theme as
well
yeah for sure but bloodraven almost
makes me think of hatsumia fenring as in
like bloodraven is someone who's super
powerful and who you almost might think
could have fulfilled the prophecy in
himself in some sense but but no he's
he's like he's super powerful but he's
relegated to the sidelines and that's
sort of similar to hasmir fendering who
was like almost a quizzes had Iraq but
not quiet and he's powerful but he
doesn't quite get to take the stage
himself and he allows others to exist on
that Central stage instead of him which
is I don't know maybe there's something
there
that's kind of um that makes me think a
little bit to jump into a fantasy series
that we haven't mentioned yet is Wheel
of Time where spend a long time the show
does it much quicker but in the books it
takes a long time for them to
reveal who the the true chosen one in
the dragon reborn there's all these
different candidates it could be this
person it could be and then they reveal
that that's been going on for for
decades that people every once in a
while there's like oh this could be the
dragon reborn it's like oh nope that
wasn't them and these it's kind of like
it's a riffing on the concept of a
messiah or the false Messiah or the
false prophet uh and then but George and
Frank Herbert they just have a a much
different Twist on on how to do this and
especially George because he's just
writing a larger scale story uses a lot
of different variations of it where it's
the centerpiece of
later in Dune I suppose you could say or
early and later I guess
yeah
yeah I think that's definitely an
argument in Song of Ice and Fire And in
June that you know that there won't
necessarily be a true hero a true hero
of the prophecy who is the person who
saves the world it's it's more just you
know the the idea of a hero is a
powerful idea that exists in every
culture and eventually someone will come
along and be a central person in in
saving the world and you know perhaps we
will say that that person was the hero
but but you know that's not necessarily
how the prophecies work it's more of
just an idea and someone will happen to
to fit it
um For Better or For Worse
um like you know Dune never really gives
us a completely conclusive answer on who
the quiz at tadarack is
um because you know spoilers for June
but you know you can argue that Paul
didn't quite fulfill his Destiny and
maybe later the second is more the real
person who changes the world and knows
everything and is super powerful like
the quizzes had a rack but then uh you
know Duncan Idaho has arguably more of a
claim to being the quiz that's had Iraq
when spoiler Duncan gets resurrected
hundreds of times
um and and so and so Frank sort of loses
interest with the idea of there being
one absolute Mega hero
um Frank was interested in constant
change
um and it's it's more the idea of the
hero that is significant than any one
person fulfilling that role and I can
see that happening with A Song of Ice
and Fire too because like there are
already prophecies in A Song of Ice and
Fire that are fulfilled multiple times
in different ways
like the whole you know waking a stone
dragon can fit Daenerys hatching her
eggs from petrified Stone eggs
um but I think that that also will
connect to Jon Snow I think Jon Snow
will be resurrected possibly in the
stone Winterfell Crypts and will be a
dragon in the sense that he's a
Targaryen who Embraces his Targaryen
identity so like already the prophecies
they can mean multiple things
simultaneously so that's why I don't
think we'll have one Azor ahai uh saving
the world I think that many people will
be involved which to its credit The Game
of Thrones TV show that sort of is where
they landed on the prophecy Melisandre
are one points says that uh I think that
you know Jon Snow and Azora and Daenerys
are both the prince that was promised
they both have a role to play in this
story which I think was kind of a
cop-out but I think that it also does
capture something that may be true in
the books which is that there are
multiple Heroes not just one person who
fits yeah prophecy I agree with that
yeah yeah and then they have go and had
Arya deal the killing blow to throw
another name in there you know and
I could even see I mean I don't think
there's a boss other but I could see
something even like that happening with
oh Arya wielding dark sister instead of
the cat's paw dagger it'd be a similar
kind of similar kind of thing
but yeah the this this whole United goal
of of is
things being brought to them through
memories and through dreams or through
prophecies is definitely a uniting
factor that
fits what you're saying because it's
applying to multiple characters you have
bran coming through it by being
discovered like he was born with the
right traits and they've chosen him
because of that and maybe they're
they've looked for other people and
discarded other candidates perhaps prior
to that
and
in the case of Danny we discussed and
John how their
circumstances and dreams have guided
them and mentors and there's connections
and parallels between these mentors and
then yeah the same thing with Paul
except that for him it's uh
it's leans it's more of is more of all
these things kind of combined whereas uh
maybe you could say the song of fire
versions are like reflections of a a
crystal and adding up to that one
like acceptance Crystal with many facets
yes indeed
so you mentioned I like some of the oh
go ahead
so you mentioned Arya killing the night
King in Game of Thrones season eight uh
at the end of June book one Aaliyah
kills Vladimir uh with a with a little
knife just how Arya kills the night king
with a knife so so both of them have a
girl using a little weapon to uh kill
the bad guy in the end it doesn't
she kill him with a needle isn't it a
needle with the uh in in Dune it's the
gomja bar needle
um and yeah that's right which Arya
wields needle
yeah which is fantastic
um that's cool Alia and Arya are even
similar sounding like name wise you know
and they both are the dark sister they
are the sister that sort of goes off on
the strange path and strange mystical
influences and comes back changed and
comes back touched and comes back as a
sort of scary
scary individual or no one's quite sure
what to deal with and they are unique
and they are isolated and they are
subject to dark Forces and it's like who
is this person now
yeah that sounds like both of them
that's great yeah and I'll yeah Aliyah
even has memories that aren't hers and
which Arya gets a bit of that when she
puts on the little girl's face she has
memories of that girl of that ugly girl
and presumably that's not going to be
the only time this happens so even that
has a bit of a parallel to other
people's memories
yeah
yeah they yeah they both have have a
variety of mystical powers that no one
else in the story has because Arya is
both a faithless man and a skin changer
are your skin changes a cat and sees
through a cat's eyes so there's all
these in the books and so there's
there's all these unique powers that
they have that um that make him very
strange and they of course are the the
sister of
um a heroic protagonist in both stories
so uh big similarities there
don't the face dancers of Dune also
acquire memories of their of people when
they
duplicate them or copy them like The
Faceless Men isn't that also kind of a
carryover uh it's it's complicated the
face dances evolve so that they like
gain the ability they gain new abilities
that they didn't have before which I
think allows them to retain memories in
ways that they couldn't before
um yeah yeah shape copyers who not only
copied the surface memories of their
victims but the deepest thoughts and
identity as well as a form of
immortality and the slaylocks who use
face dancers to make themselves Immortal
copying themselves through face density
but then the face dances become too
powerful and then they go Rogue and
they're against the talaxu and then they
have cat people called futas who serve
them and come from outside the universe
I'm not even gonna get into what happens
inheritance
yeah the face dances are like kind of
maybe the ultimate bad in the final book
of Dune because there's the many faced
one who the honored batteries are
fleeing and it's it's a whole thing I
mean they're sort of like faced one
really oh yeah it's kind of like the
great other in in June in many faced God
yeah cheers and then Daniel and Marty at
the very end of chapter house are the
author self-insert characters and they
also simultane geniusly ah evolved face
dances so look yeah I'm we we're not
even gonna get into that but there
certainly are like strong parallels
between their face dancers and The
Faceless Men
suffice to say
um someone in the live chat Brian
Shattuck just said that uh God Emperor
has a Brienne uh and what what are you
kidding what Brian means is that uh in
book four God emperor of June there's a
character called siona who is a I
believe a blonde woman who is very tall
and physically strong and physically
tough and is like not super smart but is
super loyal and is like well-intentioned
and it's interesting that siona
well that's a huge parallel so spoilers
for book four uh siona ends up
playing a role in killing her master
later the second the god Emperor siona
ends up helping in the downfall of the
person to whom she is devoted and I
think that is similar to the idea that
Brienne might kill Lady stoneheart
Brienne is sworn to serve Catelyn and
she's motivated by her loyalty to
Catelyn but a lot of people speculate
that Brienne might kill stoneheart and I
think that is quite likely so very
similar to siona helping kill later
oh Nazi on it yeah you're right sorry
it's naziona it is what what what's so
bloody name uh it's not siona it is is
someone in the live chat tell me what
her name is she's the big big tough
blonde woman the fish speaker
what on Earth is her name why have I
forgot well it doesn't it doesn't matter
someone will tell me in the chat
yes they will Naila was it
might have been nailer uh all right
let's continue what should we discuss
next should we discuss King bran
sure let's do that
so yeah King bran good one
uh yeah so at the end of Game of Thrones
season eight uh bran the the omniscient
tree boy God
uh becomes king and it's a bit weird no
one quite understands who bran is or
what he knows or what his purpose is and
what his Destiny is and how it all
happened and similarly in book four the
emperor of the universe is later the
second Atreides who is a giant worm God
who lives for 4 000 years and who does
all these sort of messed up tyrannical
things
um
uh for the greater good supposedly
which has similarities to bloodraven Who
does these messed up things supposedly
for the greater good so I've got to
wander will King brand really be a good
thing for Westeros or will King bran be
an immortal omniscient Tyrant who rules
for thousands of years and messes with
everybody what are your reckon as these
well I don't know that we'll find out uh
I think he'll George will leave us
ambiguous Clues if it if it does end in
something like that uh I think that
even all the lessons of power he's going
to have
trade and it's a huge variety of ways
throughout the story I don't think we're
going to look on it as a great thing
I think we might look on it as something
that would be good for a while
but will not be good in the long run
like all these other power structures
all these other things that wield so
much power especially putting it in one
of individual and
yeah I don't think we'll be left with a
feeling that it's going to go well in
the long term even if it'll probably
work out in the short term because the
the short term will have been so bad
prior to the settling of events at the
end uh
and
um yeah otherwise other than that it's
pretty hard to see though because
what kind of a king is he going to be
what kind of shape is the realm going to
be who else is going to be around is it
going to be a new form of government are
we going to get that far like
I I wonder it seems on one hand it seems
like there is a lot of time for that
because
you know how long will it take for the
others to be defeated and how much of
the aftermath are we going to see George
is a big fan of the scouring of the
Shire and the way The Hobbit ended with
a lot of extra stuff at the end and I
kind of feel like he's going to do the
same thing and not just end it
um suddenly I think he's going to go
into a good bit of what happens after a
lot of the major events are resolved
but not a you know not for years worth
so it's it has to be
the future is going to have to be shown
to us
in like in terms of
what we expect and not we're not going
to actually see it you know
part of me would kind of love it if
there was like an epilogue to A Song of
Ice and Fire which is Jon Snow returning
from Exile in the north to come South
and to kill his brother King bran
because King bran has become obviously a
puppet of the old gods weirwood hive
mind Consciousness and John has to like
tragically execute his own brother his
own beloved brother because he needs to
free Westeros from this magical alien
Tyrant I uh that would be a bit George
martinian I think
where would Emperor yeah
um do you like the idea that bran might
become like a meat puppet for bloodraven
um no I don't think bloodraven has those
kind of Ambitions uh I mean maybe like
in terms of if he needs to use him to to
as a weapon I don't think he would have
designs on afterwards
uh because
yeah he never he never really tried to
enrich himself or do things for himself
I don't think uh in terms of
the things we'd see someone
would do if that's what their game end
game was so yeah I fall on the side of
no on that one I think more he he his
actions throughout his life mostly are
about
seem to be about protecting he might
know about which which lines up with him
knowing about the The Prophecy from a
younger age
I I think part of what makes Dragon
through his dreams bloodraven has that
line where he says you know there was a
brother I loved there was a woman I
desired like it it does highlight that
bloodraven does have these personal
desires and I think we are invited to
wander if bloodraven's fanatical
opposition to the blackfyres was
motivated not just by protecting the
realm not just by protecting the
prophetic Targaryen bloodline but also
just by his personal beef with bitter
steel and their rivalry for Tiara sea
star so I I think it is like an open
question like is bloodraven really
acting in everyone's best interests or
does he have personal desires that he
that he puts first it's that love is the
death of Duty thing
um yeah and I also love the idea that
bloodraven still has
um a relationship with Sierra Seastar if
she are a sea star is quaith I really
like the idea of Sheriff's Easter being
quite even though it's a bit tin foily
um maybe their love endures for better
or us
so uh yeah guys I somehow take I
somewhat take that as him you know
expressing that's how he used to be
that's how he used to feel but who knows
that doesn't really speak to what he
feels now
what well I mean there's a lot of like
visual symbolism similarities between
um bloodraven and Beric because when we
are introduced to Beric dondarians in
the books he's sitting on a weirwood
throne he has one eye
he does he have one another black cloak
and yeah he does he has one eye you're
right yeah he has a black cloak
he looks like a zombie he's all like
half okay and dead he's in a cave
underground so Barrick is super similar
to blood River and I think part of the
similarity is that Barrick has lost his
Humanity
um and bloodraven I think also has lost
a lot of his Humanity because the man's
a tree
um and you know when bran talks to
bloodraven he's like are you the crow
and bloodraven's like oh I guess I'm the
crow long ago I was kind of a crow and
you know a lot has been made of that
quote
um arguing that bloodraven is not really
bloodraven but I think that you know
part of the point is that bloodraven has
lost his memories in any sense of like
blood blood ribbon doesn't do anything
that is very targaryeney like bran does
not know him as brynden rivers or as a
Targaryen bastard brand knows bloodraven
is the three-eyed Crow and and I think
that that is what he is he has lost so
much of his Targaryen identity he's lost
so much of his soul and his emotion and
he really is largely just a goddamn tree
and um he's part of a collective yeah so
suppose we can expect something similar
with bran and and that's sort of what
happens with later the second the god
Emperor like he has the other other
memories of of lifetimes and lifetimes
of other people's experiences in his
mind and as a result he is no longer
later
inside anymore you start to bleed
together with him don't they yeah
so yeah similar thing and see that
something like that may be happening
with Bran or maybe that sort of vaguely
what's what has happened with Annie and
her memories
um
with her ancestors sort of like calling
to her or whatever we've got a Joe
magician in the live chat welcome Joe
magician oh hey Geo magician Joe
magician has many wonderful Song of Ice
and Fire Youtube videos everyone should
go check out and subscribe to Joe
magician as well as go in and live
subscribing history of Westeros as well
Link in the description uh but Joe
magician in the chat says that the
epilogue will be the scouring of slavers
Bay like the scouring of the shy of Lord
of the Rings where good King Dario will
bring peace to Asos
my good King Dario
that is heavily foreshadowed
do you think Dario is is secretly euron
Aziz
of course of course euron is is about 17
different characters including uh Cersei
and Benjamin
yeah that's right yeah
uh should we talk some more about the uh
oh do you want to talk about like the
old gods and the benejeret and the whole
sort of memory thing
sure
it's a good little we've kind of touched
on that a little bit here let's let's go
deeper on that
um
yeah so they've been it seems like one
of the main parallels is a a sort of a
chosen one-ish type figure which
Paul comes up in a different couple
different ways that way whereas
it's facet of it into Song of Ice and
Fire falls on bran as opposed to maybe
John or Danny or maybe Arya
um so
and bloodraven explains the Rarity here
and maybe doesn't go so far as to call
him
a chosen one but a person of unusual
skill that's necessary uh for victory um
but I'm not sure where you fall on that
whether uh
it is more distinctly you know you're
the one uh or just the one right now
yeah I tend to think it's more of a one
right now
um but I I think it's uh interesting how
the Bennett jazzer and the old gods are
both defined by Memories the bandages
are at Reverend mothers they become
Reverend mothers by acquiring the
genetic memories of all their female
ancestors and it's that knowledge that
defines them and it's that knowledge
that empowers their schemes and their
plans
and similarly that the old gods it seems
that when a person dies their soul goes
into the weirwood trees and goes into
the old gods and the old gods are a
store of memories and knowledge
um and the children of the forest are
connected to that and bloodraven is
connected to that and that empowers
their schemes and and it's powerful but
it's also dangerous because
it's dehumanizing to be connected to all
these other consciousnesses apart from
your own
um it's interesting that the bandages
are like they are they are feminine they
are like a typically like nurturing
Force symbolically and the old gods are
connected to trees and and nature like
the children of the forest and nature
elves basically
um and yet despite that sort of maternal
natural nurturing Vibe there's a
Sinister nature to the benedjesaret and
to the weirwoods and the old gods
um so it's this sort of horror of a
Consciousness that is greater and older
than yourself
um the horror of the hive mind which can
yeah
the ancient wisdom that just is so much
smarter than you are it seems
overwhelming like how could you possibly
defeat such a thing because it's been
around so long and knows so much it is
part of the horror aspect I think some
of the horror influence and maybe if you
Branch out into maybe somewhere the real
world influences are is that these these
guys both
a lot of through a lot of the Red Scare
where communism was seen kind of that
way in a lot of ways of being a hive
mind of where everybody is the same
where you don't have individuality and
that's where some of the Sinister
elements come not that I'm Pro communism
but obviously Americans living in that
era were
overwhelmed with anti-communism stuff it
was their main enemy their main
Boogeyman
then you know that nuclear stuff came in
a little later but those things came
together
but those are both in Dune and and you
know destructive Grand destructive power
exists in A Song of Ice and Fire and
George has written a lot of his other
stories that involve like hive mind mind
control type stuff the The harangan Hive
minds of his thousand worlds uh setting
are all about mind control and slave
races and some of those are engineered
and then uh on the smaller scale his a
song for lyanna Leah yeah a song for
Leah where it's like a he wrote after a
breakup and the two characters like one
of them slowly you know joins this like
hive mind and
he loses her to that you know and he
he's tempted to join it too and you know
so these are things these authors both
have lots of influences on I think and
had written about elsewhere so it's it's
like this is the the culmination of of
that having written about it and thought
about it so much they placed it here in
their masterpieces
yeah well well George uh like all great
writers does his best writing after a
breakup uh but you noticed some
similarities as well I think with uh the
way that Paul is is tested Paul is given
a deadly test by Gaius mahayam to
determine if he has the the power and
the Inner Strength sufficient to be the
chosen one
um which is so similar to how bloodraven
tests bran with Brands flying dream
which which is a you know he he's told
to fly or die and he sees these ice
spikes with the bones of other dreamers
impaled upon them and so and so the the
sort of wise but sort of sinister
magical Mentor subjects the hero to a
deadly test
um which they survive
um but uh there's something messed up
about how you know bloodraven and Gaius
are willing to risk the lives of this
child in order to find the powerful
Chosen One
yeah it is pretty brutal it's it gets
into the themes of like
Why Real World Human Sacrifice would
happen the they would do it not for gain
usually the reason it was done
was to prevent
some sort of
have you know mandated from the revenge
or outcome from Heaven that was
terrifying like the gods would punish
them or something you know it was it was
usually to stop something horrible from
happening rather than
which is happening here which is the
exact same thing like well they're
manipulating Bran or
Paul or whoever to
just
to stop something worse from happening
according to them you know
yeah
yeah and ultimately meddling with these
Powers may cause more uh
harm than good
yeah
we talked a bit about truth drugs uh in
both Song of Ice and Fire and dune
um we mentioned like spice and we
mentioned we would paste
um and yeah there's also the Water of
Life drug in Dune which sort of Sparks
Paul's prescience and is and his psychic
ability increasing and that's yeah
that's really similar to bran eating the
weirwood paste to open his mind
um
and I think I think we're just down to
some sort of miscellaneous points at
this point is there anything else you
want to jump to now one one other thing
about bran just we maybe have mentioned
this before or maybe just either
reiterate or re-emphasize or maybe I
didn't say it is that
Annie and Paul both have their long
harrowing journey in the desert which is
a parallel also of course it's like a
parallel of some real world religious
stuff but that aside bran had a similar
Ernie it just wasn't in the desert he
had a harrowing Beyond the Wall nearly
died to several from several different
things nearly starved you know had to
eat human flesh and didn't realize it
you know all these other things uh which
is
a marker that they're on a similar
journey of gotta suffer to become a hero
and then you're strong enough to do to
face the even bigger challenge that
affects everyone
and uh yeah uh where it's going to end I
guess we don't know in this case yet but
it seems to be we have a Vega a pretty
strong general idea
bran Heats of the tree to acquire
knowledge
it's all uh all that biblical stuff is
in there uh
seasons and climate and ecology are
themes in both stories because oh yeah
in June they want to transform the
deserts of Iraqis into a more hospitable
climate and in Westeros the seasons are
irregular which creates this challenge
to survive and uh the George Martin has
said that at the end of A Song of Ice
and Fire the seasons The Irregular
seasons will be resolved so perhaps they
will you know come into balance and
regularity
um similar to Iraqis becoming more
hospitable
hmm that makes sense that's cool
about blue eyes being a big part about
story is you get the others and the
whites yeah versus the slice of pretty
different context but still blue eyes
you know big deal very important
we mentioned the maestas the sort of
academic academic smart people who serve
the Lords but might sometimes plot
against them being similar to the
mentats in Dune who are the smart
mathematical uh Giga brains who serve
Lords uh Suk doctors there's one at a
time two which is kind of you know like
a yeah they're trained at a school and
then they're distributed to the Lords
and some people suspect uh plots and
machinations and Bene jesar had also uh
you know these uh smart capable people
who were distributed to Lords but some
people suspect them of conspiracies and
manipulations
there are one gender uh obviously that
that maesters were one gender and the
beneficiary are all one gender right
yeah yeah I I guess the closest thing A
Song of Ice and Fire has to an
all-female order is the silent sisters
who are intriguing
indeed
um and maybe we should what else do we
have talk about just some of the deeper
fundamental like sort of moral messages
and thematic messages of the story
um I I feel that you know Dune is very
much about saying that hey like
superheroes are bad Messiahs and leaders
are potentially catastrophic like we
should not follow heroic leaders whereas
I feel that A Song of Ice and Fire Like
A Song of Ice and Fire definitely
questions and complicates the tropes of
heroism but I think that ultimately
George does love the Romantic tropes of
Heroes being heroic and I think Brienne
is a great
um example of that George loves
brienne's heroism and her willingness to
fight for what's right
um and John's willingness to fight for
what's right
I don't I don't think the ending of a
song of Eyes on Fire will be
we were stupid for following John and we
were stupid for following Daenerys and
and Brienne I I think that George does
value their heroism in a way that Frank
Herbert does not value heroism I think
that Frank Herbert values more cold
rational cunning and Enlightenment and
thinking on a higher plane in a way that
George does not
yeah I think that's a that's pretty
insightful way to put it I think and I
think uh George sometimes gets accused
of being too Grim but there's always
these lights within this darkness that
he paints like you said On's a good
example Ned's a good example you know
brienne's a good example these
characters do good things that they
suffer consequences for in Heroes charge
is not unrealistic about the fates of
people that do good that doesn't
it also shows
things and and how those things carry
forward even without those people's
lives continuing like like Ned and
presumably some of these other
characters will also die and will be
their memories will matter to those that
that continue yeah those that don't
uh yeah yeah call me an optimist but I
think that George Martin has a better
hope of concluding and ending his series
because I I think George Martin is more
conventional in his storytelling like
George is very much into questioning and
complicating tropes but he ultimately I
think is writing a story about heroism
and goodness triumphing over corruption
and despair and that is not what Frank
Herbert does with dune Frank Urban in
June is is
insatiably interested in
rationally
rethinking and reframing and
recontextualizing situations and
accepting no conclusion Frank and June
will accept no
status quo will accept no ending because
life for him is all about new beginnings
and new discoveries and and questioning
everything constantly so so I think
that's part of you know like like both
June and A Song of Ice and Fire are
unfinished series currently at least in
my view some people well no they are
both unfinished series
um
so so yeah I tend to think that George
might be able to stick some kind of a
landing whereas Frank Herbert I think
with Chapter House did not
[Music]
um
but there's definitely something yeah
and then there's
going go ahead
well there's also
um I think similarities in sort of the
structure of the series in how you know
both both series started out with like
three books that were well received and
fairly action-packed and then the fourth
book and the fifth book become a lot
more Meandering and a lot more indulgent
and sort of philosophical
um and introducing new characters and
plot lines I I think that both Frank and
George they got a little bit too
indulgent and undisciplined in
introducing more and more stuff and I
think that's part of why they haven't
finished their series
um in that sense they have a similar
style of writing I think
it could be there maybe just more
interested in the process than or the
journey than destination in a lot of
ways because they're writing
entire worlds and that's that conflicts
with writing a story not just worlds but
universes
uh especially given in George's case I
know less about Frank but in George's
case I know that
he is to view this story as you know
what you the history and whatever's in
there is supposed to serve the story but
that was before his his work became a
franchise
and when those other World building
details became valuable whereas they
wouldn't be in they would just be fun in
most stories yeah that's true so
it's changed for him so it's the picture
and the the opportunity has changed for
him I'm not sure that was ever the case
for Frank because
if you know he got his shows I mean his
books were adapted
they didn't achieve this level not
during his life I mean Dune is still
being remade constantly
historically speaking and doing well
but Frank's not there to see it and
whereas you know or just having a bit of
a different Peak
yeah yeah I think you make a good point
that like both George and Frank they had
major popular adaptations screen
adaptations of their work while they
were still writing the book series and I
think for both Frank and George that
gave them a huge commercial incentive to
make a whole bunch more Dune and make a
whole bunch more Game of Thrones and I
think that ironically that may have
prevented both of them from concluding
their series at a certain point uh Frank
Herbert in interviews said that I will
not write more Dune books he said that
those three that those first three June
books that was it that was all there
would be and then because of the success
of June and the popularity of the movie
and stuff that's why he wrote book four
and then book five and book six so and I
think in a funny sort of similar way
it's the success of the Game of Thrones
TV show that has largely distracted
George from finishing the books and has
perhaps even encouraged him to be overly
perfectionist and to be overly indulgent
with the later books that he's writing
so so in a really ironic way the the
mainstream success of the series may
have prevented these series from having
conclusions
yeah isn't that funny and it's also
uh
a bit of a parallel like for different
reasons but George initially planned his
story to be a Trilogy it wasn't because
of the TV show that he expanded it
obviously that expansion happened
earlier but it's funny to think that
Frank also was going to stop after three
books and expanded it Beyond and just
George his plans changed before he got
to that point but it was still uh
something they had in common about the
when they conceived it initially yeah
uh call calls knock in the live chat
says that as hard as George Martin's
characters have it they never give up
they want to live and win the day no
matter how flawed their personal
philosophy and he says that there are no
nihilists in A Song of Ice and Fire they
all follow their passions and and yeah I
think that's another that's a great way
to say it because
um because the characters in June are
not like that like like the characters
in Dune do wrestle with similar ideas of
like love versus Duty with like later
II's love for Hui no Ray and all of that
but like the the Dune books almost
always land on the side of
be a hard ass
Machiavellian rationalist the only way
to survive is to embrace the harsh
rationalist
um perspective follow your brain not
your heart is often I think the message
of Dune
um I think Frank Herbert sort of
softened a little bit in his later books
and he suddenly ends chapter house with
with a more emotional human side but um
I think overall June is a lot more harsh
and like rationalistic than
A Song of Ice and Fire which is
ultimately very human and emotional and
romantic and full of heart yeah well
said I totally agree with that I think
it is especially I mean even without
having seen the ending yet I think we
can agree that there are more positive
portrayals of relationships and
positive outlooks and the metaphor I
used before was lights in the darkness
and a different Outlook like you say
more Herbert's maybe is more focused on
Surviving like you said whereas maybe
George isn't as obsessed with surviving
yeah yeah
whereas just a good life is or valuable
than surviving like eating out a few
extra years isn't just like what is what
is that again the Mary mazdoor lesson
what is a few extra years worth if those
are bad years right if you're if you're
suffering for those did you really want
those years right so yeah
quantity versus quality is maybe part of
backing up part of that debate there and
uh From A Distant perspective I guess
yeah I think that's a fantastic point
because like Frank Herbert in Dune is
very interested in like survival of the
human species as the absolute priority
and he has this very sort of like
evolutionary biological perspective
where he's like you know it's about the
survival of the species and our
evolution in order to continue George
Martin is not so much into that George
Martin is more interested in like
preservation of the human Spirit of like
yes healthy human emotions and goodness
and and and I think that George Martin
in a funny way like the absolute
survival of the human race is is not his
priority I don't think George Martin in
A Song of Ice and Fire fears the
extinction of humanity quite in the same
way that Frank Herbert does
um that's a great way to put it yeah to
frame it yeah yeah which which obviously
you know we're speculating about an
unfinished series uh you know I think we
will learn a lot more of this when
Humanity faces an apocalyptic threat
from the white walkers in the later
books but um yeah I think Frank and
George have a very different priorities
in that sense as well
like two examples that George uses to
really drive this point home one of them
is
very straightforward because it's almost
like a moral riddle playing out right in
front of you and it's pretty clear who
he thinks the person that's right is and
that's Davos arguing with Stannis over
sacrificing Rick storm yeah there's
there's very little doubt in the
reader's mind who's right there and he's
and even though Stannis is like yeah but
the whole world could depend on it's
like yeah but that was like yeah but
it's wrong this is a child like it's
definitely was like yeah what's the
world what about a once what's one child
worth over the case like he's like
everything and you're like yeah Davos is
Right everything yeah
and uh and then another one is like when
tywin's like well what's what's worse 10
killing ten thousand men in battle or a
few men at dinner and tyrion's like
doesn't know what to say to that but
you're left thinking yeah but that's
you're wrong about that that's not right
not to mention it's not really what
happened but with the Red Wedding
thousands of people were slaughtered at
dinner but that but let's say Tywin was
being honest there you'd still be like
morally uncomfortable that's like I
don't know if that's true though you
know like just uh so the bad guys are I
mean not the Taiwan and sandus are
anywhere near the same type of character
but Stannis was clearly flirting with
the the moral fork in the road that is
at least from George's point of view I
think is clearly defined you may
disagree you you out there might
disagree with
with Stannis and Davos there you might
disagree with Tywin you might agree with
Tywin but I don't think it's I don't
think there's much doubt on who George
agrees with and I think George
definitely agrees with Davos and George
definitely doesn't agree with Tywin
because like you said I think he put it
really well it's about preserving the
soul of humanity rather than the
quantity or
totality of humanity
yeah yeah I I think that is such a good
point about Stannis and edrick storm I
think that moment is the Heart of A Song
of Ice and Fire in a lot of ways like
it's that idea of
you know will you sacrifice a literal
innocent human child for the sake of
winning
um and even for the sake of saving the
realm and and yeah as you say the answer
is no you should not like we should not
sacrifice our soul for anything it it
would be better for us to go extinct
than for us to sacrifice our souls and
our compassion whereas in Dune the
message of June is you should absolutely
sacrifice your human compassion
survival because that's what the god
Emperor lato does in book four he he
oppresses Humanity cruelly for three
thousand years for the sake of our
survival and you know even Paul Paul's
Jihad in which he kills billions of
people and sterilizes entire planets
um I mean it's sort of framed as a bad
thing but like but like kind of not as
well like it like it was just the
necessary part of his Ascension and in
the conversation Paul has with later in
book three three lato says that yeah you
committed a genocide and killed
trillions of people and you didn't go
far enough is what later says in book
three later tells Paul you you were too
much of a to do what was necessary
in completely suffocating the world so I
was like genocide was not it was not
enough and so it's like oh my God Franco
but like you know George would rather
sacrifice Humanity than than kill one
bastard boy but Frank is entirely
willing to
um subjugate a universe for the sake of
our survival so yeah that that may be
the key the the heart of the difference
between George Martin and Frank Herbert
that's pretty good yeah I think I I
hadn't thought about this nearly as much
I like how much we've gotten into it
just kind of naturally during this
discussion yeah someone Lucas hunt in
the live chat says who is Tywin
Lannister's parallel in tune I would say
the closest parallel to Tywin Lannister
is goddamn later the second the god
emperor of June like June book four is
like what if Tywin was the emperor of
the universe like that is what book four
is like because lato is the ultimate
Machiavellian I will sacrifice
everything for like the survival and I
mean you know Tywin is more
self-interested Tywin is more proud and
self-interested and he's got daddy
issues but but in terms of like make
sacrificing anything to win and in terms
of like making those you know what is
killing a hundred men at dinner compared
to killing a thousand on the battlefield
like that is something that later God
Emperor would say so um yeah like Taiwan
absolutely sacrificed The Souls of his
all his children like in in that sense
like he made them all they all turned
out serious issues because of his goals
right like that's these are like you can
draw a line from one to the other and
his pride yeah
yeah
um I think that we should wrap this up
shortly this was a wonderful chat I
think we've covered a lot of um
interesting ground
yeah I had like three quickies quick fun
ones oh yeah absolutely wanted to wrap
up with some miscellaneous if that's
cool yeah but for that we'll spend some
time answering the last of the super
chats so if anyone's got anything they
desperately want us to chat about uh let
us know but uh yeah let's um finish up
with some fun miscellaneous things
so one I think is Duncan Idaho and
Duncan the tall I mean Duncan is not the
not a super rare name but it's a kind of
an odd name to be in A Song of Ice and
Fire now both theories are noted for not
really going to at first at least with
using a lot of familiar names in
George's case he uses ones that are just
slightly different like Joffrey is it a
Jeffrey or yeah uh your Ned Ned eddard
instead of eduard you know right there
are so many different examples like that
in this language and Fire
yeah whereas Dune uses all these
biblical names
out of like Middle Eastern names that
aren't as familiar to a lot of Western
readers but still are like Earth names
um
yeah Duncan and Duncan they have a lot
in common besides their name too
yeah I think I saw some funny tweet that
was about how like you know June is like
you know that there's a character called
tayakanik and shaddam and and all these
wild names and there's a guy called like
Fred or George like Paul you know yeah
it's kind of funny the different Vibes
they use for the languages
we also have uh
it's another one
um
it's a wildling named halleck and uh
hair in the black's father was also
named halek halicor I don't know if that
might be a nod to Gurney
yeah not just be get anyhow like halleck
is how like a common name I don't I
don't know any helix
I Googled halek like 15 minutes ago in
advance of this little note and I just
there's a couple and it comes up a
couple times but it's not yeah it
doesn't seem very common or famous for
much so I feel like it's probably
connected at least you know maybe a nod
yeah
cool
um
it's interesting how dragons seem to be
involved in the creation of Valyrian
steel in A Song of Ice and Fire which is
like the crucial weapon and Indian sand
worms are the source of Chris knives
which are the important weapons like
Valyrian steel and also sand worms make
the spice which is the all-important
drug so like the the big powerful
monster is the source of like tools and
weapons and power
um as well
that's true that's pretty cool yeah I
hadn't thought I hadn't thought about
the
the Chris knife and Valyrian steel combo
I had noticed the pale white glow as and
noticed that would be a parallel to Dawn
and the worthiness to wield it which is
a parallel to Dawn but that's not really
an in direct influence but that's more
of a recurring Trope in mythology of the
worthiness to wield like you know
Excalibur or ill near or any number of
famous weapons that you have to be of
certain character or whatever to wield
yeah yeah Frank Herbert talked about the
sand worm as like the archetypal monster
that the hero must face the Beast the
dragon guarding the gold
um so it's appropriate that like the
archetypal Beast monster that the hero
must face is the source of the sword the
special magic sword the blade the hero
wields
um and George suddenly plays with that
with his dragons and Valyrian steel as
well
oh right on
uh here's one from our friend Nina shout
out to good
queenalley.tumblr.com she pointed out
that irlan gives Chinese sneaks shiny
contraceptives a shiny takes fertility
treatments and kind of counteracts that
I guess and in this in Game of Thrones
civil westerling uh gives her own
daughter uh contraceptives and tells her
their fertility drugs
to prevent it from conceding with Rob
and Jane even
talks about how she's
expecting to have twins she's like
excited she's gonna have twins
she obviously doesn't but um deepens the
potential parallel there yeah
interesting interesting and also you
know Jane and Rob's relationship is sort
of a forbidden and ill-advised one in
the same way that Jessica objects to
chani and Paul's relationship because
it's not the best political move
yes very good because we've already made
a ton of cattle and Jessica parallels so
that that fits in there that category
very nicely yeah excellent yeah rub yeah
yeah no yeah that's really interesting
and yeah absolutely absolutely check out
um good Queen alisane on Tumblr Nina
Friel does something yeah yeah really
excellent Song of Ice and Fire analysis
very insightful stuff yes but a lot of
real world parallels too she's good with
that yeah okay my last one my last one
this is pure fun it was a very recent
episode of Futurama
at from the re-re-re-reboot of Futurama
um
which had a
icro Adventure inside a cat litter box
or a litter box I guess it was I don't
know if it was cat litter I forget
anyway they were it was doomed
like Dune you know but doing there was
worms in there and they were like the
sand worms and Futurama course is made
by the same creators as The Simpsons and
The Simpsons uh did A Game of Thrones
episode so Futurama did it do an episode
Simpson did A Game of Thrones episode
there you go
we need to we need to we need a dune
explained video stat don't we
yes Doom d-o-n-g right I think that was
uh
um
around the time that the gene book came
out in the 60s there was like a parody
book that came out that was called Dune
d-o-o-n
uh and it was like some uh just some
parody of June that came out you always
forget that like you know the 60s is
when June came out such a different time
in terms of media yeah
um the idea of like parody books coming
out is is not something that uh that
happens a lot in 2023 is it yeah
parodies of popular movies coming out in
book form but uh you know I guess that's
what we did before
YouTube and dictator okay so what what
year did uh what year did the first book
Dune come out 65 I think
as uh I'm pretty sure George R Martin
was born
he was a teenager when
uh JFK I'd say he was born in 48 yeah so
he would have been 17 when Dune came out
so that's like yeah right in his wheel
his developing nerd brain wheelhouse
right there
pretty perfect yep
slides right in there with those Marvel
Comics we mentioned earlier Stan Lee was
doing his thing and
Nick Herbert was emerging on the scene
with a game changer
I would have been so fascinating to hear
them have a conversation
yeah it really would have been that's
true I wonder I wonder if they uh I
wonder if that ever happened I wonder if
they're I'm sure their paths must have
crossed a few times but doesn't mean
they had like discussions or
you know
let alone anything more substantial than
that
be something worth researching official
all right well let's uh respond to the
last of the super chats and then I think
we will wrap up this live stream thanks
for listening everybody please like And
subscribe and we will uh
have a look uh thank you for the Super
Chat from Professor 13n who says love
the content have you seen the Game of
Thrones RPG it came out before A Feast
for Crows and is super interesting shout
out to Stannis the one true king and
Thaddeus Rowan have you played the Game
of Thrones RPG Aziz
never played it but I look at the rule
books uh they're they're used to be some
lore from it that was cited it's maybe
more considered Sammy Cannon now but
there were some things about like
at least the monster is and a few other
characters that popped up in there that
were small little tidbits that were fun
so you know in our effort to try to
learn every little bit of lore we had to
look at those things but I I never
actually played it which is too bad
because it seems like it would have been
fun
yeah I Professor might also be referring
to the video game RPG that came out
which um which I I also haven't played
but some people say that it's good it
looks a little bit
um
uh I don't know so it doesn't look like
the easiest game to get into but
apparently it's good
yeah there were a couple of there was
like a A Game of Thrones Conquest which
is a who didn't do very well and there
was the one where you could play the
Night's Watch character in the relore
priest which I did play a little bit of
and then there's the tk3 and ck2
Crusader Kings two and three song wise
fire mods that I stream on Fridays which
are like full you're playing the whole
Dynasty through like playing out the
character until they take over as their
air then there's a mountain blade did an
um a mod as well so you could play
sieges and small parties skirmishing and
fighting and normally it's set in a
regular like medieval setting but
there's a there was a mod for for
Westeros and it was it was quite good
yeah quite good I don't know I don't
know if it's been updated or if there's
a new one or whatever but there are a
lot of good Game of Thrones RPGs out
there and I imagine there's more coming
one of these days it is wild to me
though the the literal most popular TV
show of our era
um the the best video game adaptations
that it has are mods made by fans the
people who own this IP have not managed
to turn the most popular fantasy
story of our time into a decent into a
popular good video game which is um good
point a bit ridiculous thanks for the
fumble isn't it thanks for the Super
Chat from Sir flemint Brax who says I'm
starting a fund for a new durkheim video
from shift yeah one of the really really
early old shift x videos was about a
sociology Theory from Emile durkheim
uh that's a very old video so I I have
no memory of whether that video is any
good or not but I'm glad that I'm glad
that people have enjoyed it and we have
made more non-fiction videos like the
religion and disaster video and I would
like to make uh more non-fiction videos
in future so uh look out for that's cool
yeah right on thanks for the Super Chat
encourage you that as well yeah thanks
thanks you Cass who says I'm here for
Wallace and Ruble and a Sprinkle of
Winkles on my dinkle thank you for that
Cass excuse me
and thank you Among Us law who said last
year you said the Winds of Winter will
come out next year or never
are we doomed as these are we doomed
I don't think we're doomed you know it's
a funny silver lining of the
U.S writers and actors strike is that
all of George's Hollywood projects are
Paws so he really
do anything else but work on the book
and from what we've heard we know a
couple of his people he's written quite
a lot he's he's written it's going to be
the biggest book of the series probably
and uh so it's not as if he's stuck he
might be stuck in certain places but
he's not stuck overall he's been writing
and uh so yeah I remain optimistic about
at least um something but I'm not going
to put any sort of timeline on it
I've played that game before and lost
yes we all have yeah like everyone I was
a fool for trying to predict a year
um he does say that he he's two-thirds
75 no three quarters 75 percent
finished with the book is is what he
said most recently right
I think so I don't recall yeah there's
been so many updates over the years
they're all blur now yeah well I I can't
help but notice that it took him 12
years to get to three quarters of the
way and he started at one quarter of the
way because a quarter of the book was
cut from the previous book dance so if
it took him 12 years to write half the
book it could easily be six years to fit
to write the last quarter of the book if
my math is right so uh you know my yeah
don't do the math is my advice
charge isn't great at math anyway so you
know maybe it'll just work out through
his conception of math yeah that's right
we shouldn't do the math because because
Georgia doesn't do the math George is
writing process does not follow any
human mathematics so uh
to predict it
um and thanks nuisance he says is there
a chance we'll get everything we want
for the A Song of Ice and Fire Universe
even if we get the wind of winter at a
dream of spring we're not going to get
all the Duncan egg novellas
there's so much that we want yeah so
that's I guess that's kind of a in some
ways that's a low-hanging fruit answer
because I want I want some more than is
reasonable in the first place yes there
is there is no end to what we want if
George did buy some miracle deliver wins
and dream and 12 Duncan egg books and
part two of the Georgia Marillion Fire
and Blood Part Two we would just ask for
for a thousand more and I think George
knows he's in a bit of a sisyphy and
um never-ending uh uh trap which is you
know it's it's enormous success but it's
also something that he would literally
never Escape until the day that he dies
so I you know there's good and bad here
there's there's bitters yeah right I
have a question for nuisance a return
question back at them and what do you
know about de-aging and modern
um medical procedures maybe we need a
GoFundMe to invest in some cryogenic uh
uh science for Jewish Mountain but uh he
doesn't like it when people speculate
about his death
so maybe maybe we shouldn't it wouldn't
either I wouldn't want that either that
doesn't sound it doesn't uh or
13 clarifies that yeah he was talking
about the uh tabletop dnd-esque RPG Aziz
Deluxe rule book says it's an eight out
of ten
um I think it's time to wrap up this
stream it's been a long stream uh
thank you so much for joining in talking
about Song of Ice and Fire in June
yeah thanks for having me this is great
we had a lot of notes but we also had a
lot of things come up which is essence
of a good discussion when you you're
prepared but also discussion takes you
places you didn't expect you're inspired
to with new ideas and yeah this was
great this was a lot of fun this is like
I said at the beginning a niche
discussion but that's that's also that
kind of the essence of eek culture is is
finding your niches and and being
passionate about them and regarding
regardless of who else is watching or
caring uh and I think a lot of y'all did
care a lot of y'all enjoyed this
especially this person who asks if this
picture of Duke Leto and Ned Stark
meaning Sean Bean and Oscar Isaac is as
pictures of you and me
that's exactly how I look that's correct
yes we look like amalgams of them both
yes that's right
um yeah yeah no thank you so much for
coming on and you know Aziz did most of
the work writing up uh some notes uh
checking out these similarities so I'm
grateful for that and do check out
aziz's channel history of Westeros one
of the great long-running OG Song of Ice
and Fire Community
institutions is history of Westeros
though history of Westeros was one of my
Inspirations in uh covering Song of Ice
and Fire myself or not shift X so uh
definitely you definitely support him
but you're very kind thank you for that
yeah history of Westeros is our channel
name we're on all the podcast platforms
too we're a bit more of our stuff where
we do both on YouTube and podcast
platforms but we're a little bigger over
there we're trying to do more videos
because even even our podcast hosts
Spotify these days is pushing video so
yeah but this was super fun I love
having discussions with other smart
people that know their stuff
uh would put these with these great
large fandoms and we got really meta
today this is one of the most meta
discussions I've ever had we were
talking about like things that influence
them as kids and what drugs they did
all this other stuff that's that's
really getting into it man yeah no
always love getting into the the heart
of it all so um
so yeah thanks so much Aziz we'll wrap
it up everyone slap like And subscribe
and uh we'll see you next time thanks
guys
uh